foreign
so it being 9 30 we'll open our work
session on the Department of Justice and
the human rights end of things also
we've asked commissioner arlinghaus to
be here to discuss any issues the
division has with the move there's been
some questions about costs and ex some
expenses that weren't foreseen
so at that Mr attorney general if you'd
like to come forward and welcome them
have anyone else come up with you I see
the guru of the finance end of your
yeah
that's why we rely on the LBA for us or
try to make us look good so again
welcome
thank you Mr chair
good morning members of the committee my
name is John fermella attorney general
for the State of New Hampshire with me
is Kathy Carr our director of
administration as I said she will she
will help me answer the hard questions
and make me look smarter than I am when
it comes to Dollars I'm just just for
the folks watching this the budget is on
264 for those looking for where it
starts in the budget book 264.
I'm sorry for the interruption all yours
again
no problem thank you Mr chair so we have
prepared
um just a high level presentation just
to give you the highlights of our budget
and then we'll certainly be prepared to
answer any uh more detailed questions
you have and provide any follow-up
information that might be helpful but I
thought it would be helpful to start
on page two of the PowerPoint I won't go
into too much detail on this because I
did appear before you about a month ago
and went through the entire org chart
but on page two we just lay out the
roles of the Attorney General I think it
helps to give context to what what we're
doing in this budget so the first rule
of the Attorney General probably the
best known role is to serve as the chief
law enforcement officer so at the end of
the day the attorney general and the
Attorney General's office
supervise all law enforcement activities
in the state where the chief law
enforcement agency there are many cases
we handle ourselves but any there could
be any number of cases that we might
assert jurisdiction over even if they're
not typically within our bailiwick and
so we we oversee the entire law
enforcement community in in the state
attorney general also serves as the
chief prosecutor
so under our law the attorney general
has the the duty to supervise all of the
County attorneys and County attorney
offices throughout the state County
attorneys are independently elected and
they generally operate independently but
under our statutes the Attorney General
is is sort of the the ultimate backstop
in the ultimate supervisor those
activities we meet with the County
attorneys regularly every two months
we're in constant communication with
them and I think that is a a good
feature of our criminal justice system
in New Hampshire because we are all
working together we work very well with
County attorneys of both parties they're
really politics don't really come into
play for the chief prosecutors and chief
law enforcement offices and officers in
the various counties so we work very
well together we have a very good
coordinated approach across the state
the AG also serves as the chief legal
officer so we provide advice to every
state agency or just about every state
agency we provide legal advice and
representation to the legislature we
provide legal advice and representation
to the judicial branch many people don't
realize that if the judicial branch gets
sued either for employment issues or
other issues we at the Department of
Justice represent the judicial branch
that does sometimes include representing
individual judges
we have very good procedures in place to
wall off those attorneys from appearing
in front of the same judges that they're
representing to to avoid conflicts of
interest
the Attorney General also serves as as
what I like to say as really the
ultimate public protection official in
the state so in addition to to law
enforcement prosecution
representing state government the
attorney general has the ability and the
obligation to take certain actions that
are in the public interest one
a good recent example of that are the
lawsuits that the office has brought
against opioid opioid companies
manufacturers Distributors for
contributing to the opioid crisis in the
state
and then of course the attorney general
has to be a commissioner and run the
Department of Justice so that is another
role role of the Attorney General and we
also have a drug task force that that we
head up
so I think that it's helpful to go
through that from my perspective just to
sort of set the context for for what the
budget that you see in front of you is
the next page on the presentation is
this is a high level org chart we can
provide we have booklets that that break
this down even further in the various
bureaus and units but this is how the
budget looks at a high level for the
division of public protection the
division of legal counsel the medical
examiner's office and our division of
Grants management this is um
this gives you a breakdown of how many
positions are are in these various
high-level functions
one thing that is a bit confusing when
it comes to the Department of Justice is
that our org chart for Budget purposes
looks a little different than our than
our operational org chart and that is
because we
we break the office down sometimes into
units that are very small say one
attorney and one staff person sometimes
only one attorney and so for budgeting
purposes to have different I think uh
budget line items and different uh
budget breakdowns for units that are
that small would would be cumbersome so
I think for your purposes and looking at
the budget the budget org chart is is
most helpful and this is the high level
org chart we can certainly provide
further breakdowns if you want to see
say how many positions are in the
Environmental Protection Bureau or how
many positions are in the transportation
and construction Bureau we can provide
that to you but for purposes of this
high level presentation
this we provided this org chart as
you'll see and as we discussed when I
was before you about a month ago the
division of public protection is is
the bigger component of the office this
is for the most part the the part of the
office that does Criminal prosecutions
and brings enforcement actions in the
public interest
the division of legal counsel
is the next biggest part of the office
and that is
um
probably most easily conceived of as the
Civil part of the office so while the
division of public protection is the
criminal component of the office the
division of legal counsel is the Civil
part of the office the division of legal
counsel is is quite a bit smaller than
the division of public protection there
are 49 49 positions there
all total we have 166 permanent
positions we also have some temporary
positions but of 166 permanent positions
I think when you add in our temporary
positions we have Kathy can correct me
if I'm wrong but somewhere close to 190
total positions when you're talking
188 when you're talking permanent and
so skipping ahead to page five because
page four is just a nice picture of our
logo
page five is is a high level snapshot of
our budget
or I should say our
uh proposed budget in the in the
so as you will see
the budget as it's presented to you in
the governor's budget for the Department
of Justice would result in a rough an
increase from fiscal year 2023 of a
total of 40 million three hundred ninety
thousand sixty four dollars
to 43 million 598 407 and fiscal year
2024 and then an additional increase to
44 million eight twenty six Five Sixty
one and fiscal year 2025.
in percentage terms that's about a 7.9
percent increase from FY 23 to FY 24 and
then an additional roughly 2.8 percent
increase
from FY 24 to fy25
one thing I would point out which I
think is important when when sort of
thinking about the department and
thinking about its growth and this
budget increase is that and Kathy can
correct me if I'm wrong but I think
about a million dollars of this increase
in each year so pretty big chunk is
related to our new building over at
Granite place so it's not really a
that million dollars of course is it's
it's money it's taxpayer money but it
doesn't reflect what I would think of as
a growth in the department staff or
operations and I would be remiss if I
didn't say at the end of the day that
million dollars is a result of what the
legislature has asked us to do which is
which is move space so we are we're good
team players we're going to do our job
and comply with what the legislature has
asked for but I would um put in a plug
for the notion that that million dollars
is not not necessarily something we've
asked for to add on to the Department's
functions so I think that's that's
important to know when you're looking at
how much we're increasing in our budget
representative McGuire has a question
thank you and thank you thank you um Mr
farmallo
um where do where do other funds come in
because I noticed the actual for 2022
um the other funds were more like what
you're expecting for 24 and 25 so I'm
guessing the 23 number is like 2 million
too high for what you're actually gonna
get
okay
okay yeah so the other funds
the one component of the Department of
Justice's budget is our litigation funds
which typically every year we only
budget that's been the sort of the
approach of the legislature we budget
350 000 or so for litigation funds
we then come to the fiscal committee
throughout the year to to get money into
that fund so I think what you're seeing
there is we don't have a final
under the revenue line there's other
funds there's Federal General and other
right yeah so okay so your your other
was two million short of expectations I
think in 2022 I don't see it but that's
what I think
and so therefore I'm wondering is 2023
gonna come in 2 million shorts so my
I we can dig into that a little bit but
I think what that is is our consumer
protection and antitrust Bureau brings
in
um funds every year from from
settlements from enforcement actions
were capped at five million dollars so
we can't have more than five million
dollars in that fund anything more than
five million flows into the general fund
and while we generally average
more than five million because we
typically send money back to the general
fund it's not the same every fiscal year
so some fiscal years were up some fiscal
years were down but we generally average
enough to send money back to the general
fund over and above five million dollars
I think that's what you're seeing it is
difficult to budget how much revenue is
going to come in because we we don't I
mean I I have a sense of what cases were
involved in that may result in
settlements or recoveries but it's
always difficult to estimate exactly
which recoveries are going to come in in
which fiscal year they come in three or
four months later so so was the 8.7 for
2023 unrealistic
I mean what's it going to be this year
because notice the next following years
you have 6.7 6.8 well I think I think
8.7 is what we're spending
out of the in other funds is that so
correct we hope to bring in 8.7 this
year that's how we budgeted based on
history based on history we budgeted to
bring in
that much because we have
more than
70 percent of our budget is all
self-funded
we bring in
comparison very little we use very
little general funds so this
oh I'm sorry so this is the offset of
the
um what are
self-funded areas are spending and what
we expect to bring in to cover those
self-funded
funds and one of those is consumer
protection
um in history
shows that we normally bring in a little
bit more but we did not in 2022.
it's it's also not just consumer
protection right so for for our
assistant Deputy medical examiners for
instance those are paid for out sub
what 1.1 1.2 million dollars in that
range so other funds I think the
consumer protection fund is the biggest
component of other funds but it's it's
not the only component but I think the
question you're getting to
representative is and we're actually
going to talk about this later because
it's part of the reason we you'll see an
increase in general funds we have to be
careful when we budget with the consumer
protection fund because it again it we
can I think rely on an average but in
any given year it's difficult to
estimate exactly how much we're going to
bring in So when you say is it realistic
is 2023 realistic
I think the 8.7 million total probably
is realistic when you add up what we've
what we've either brought in above four
in the consumer protection fund or what
we have left over but
um again that's 2023 even estimating out
to 2024 and 2025 is difficult it's part
of the reason we have
in this budget proposed shifting some of
the items that were on other funds like
the consumer protection funds back to
General funds so that we're not
um
we don't we don't end up with a
individual fiscal year where we don't
have enough to cover what's budgeted as
far as far as operations so
it just seems weird to me because
the actual of 2022 was 6.7 you expect
this year 8.7 and then you expect the
next two years 6.7 6.7 see what I mean
why should this year be somehow
different than so four years of the
three years yeah I'm gonna yeah I'll
skip to what so what happened in the
last budget and
um I thought I did not think this was a
good idea which is why we're trying to
switch it back what happened to the in
the last budget is that
in the early part of the formation of
the budget when there was a thought that
we may we may have less General funds
available
a number of positions that are in our
criminal Bureau that aren't related to
Consumer Protection were shifted on to
the consumer protection fund to save
General funds and so we budgeted
for Consumer it was put in the budget to
say okay we're expecting this much in
other funds consumer protection funds to
cover those positions
we did cover those positions I think
that is not sustainable so what we have
proposed in this budget is to shift
those positions that are not related to
Consumer Protection back to the general
fund it's why you see that Spike and why
you see it going down so I think you've
you've caught on to the problem that we
identified and felt that we should
any further questions on on this high
level snapshot okay
you will notice that
and we've covered now a part of it you
will notice that while the overall
budget for the Department I
I guess it's sort of this isn't if I do
say so myself moment is is
um not the increase is not excessive
when you account for the million dollars
or so that's related to the new building
there is a significant increase in
general funds and so our next slide
we're going to just highlight for you
the reason for that increase in general
funds
the biggest reason is what we talked
about with regard to the shift of
positions so that takes up a big chunk
of it
but on the next slide
we have request we have requested some
additional resources which I'll which
I'll talk about
I think when I appeared before you in
about a month ago we talked about
additional resources for our elder abuse
and financial exploitation unit
so those are those are additional
resources we've requested that would be
General funded it's three new positions
a new attorney a new investigator and a
new investigative paralegal right now
our Elder Fraud Unit actually only has
one full-time attorney dedicated to it
it shares paralegals and investigators
with other other parts of the Consumer
Protection Bureau so we we really want
to dedicate more resources to elder
abuse and financial exploitation so that
is part of what accounts for our general
fund increase
the YDC criminal investigation
these are additional general fund
resources but they are temporary
resources
one or more of you may recall that a
couple years ago we came to the fiscal
committee and got approval to accept and
expend arpa funds for six temporary YDC
positions
the funding for those six temporary
positions we think is going to run out
about by about the end of fiscal year
24. and in discussing this with the
governor and discussing how we kind of
project out our need for these positions
we did rather than come back for more
arpa funds in this budget we're asking
for General funds to cover those
positions for fiscal year 25.
we don't expect that these are going to
be permanent positions we don't think
we're going to need them for years and
years but they it does result in a
general fund increase in this budget
so we're trying to
one of the things we've tried to do
internally is spread out some of the YDC
work
not just within our contemporary YDC
unit but to other lawyers in the office
so that we don't have to have these
additional temporary resources for for
many many years for now we're asking for
the general funds for fiscal year 25 but
it is my hope and it's our goal that
when we come back for the next budget we
can decrease at a minimum decrease any
ask for further temporary resources
because we're trying to build build our
efforts on YDC into the wider criminal
Bureau so that we're not necessarily
causing that to grow the office
permanently
the next reason for the general fund
increase I've already covered that's
moving some of the criminal some of the
non-consumer protected criminal
positions off of the consumer protection
fund and back on to the general fund
I think that's the right way to go for a
couple reasons one in representative
McGuire kind of identified this you put
yourself in I think budget difficulties
when you when you start relying on
unreliable funds for what are really
ongoing operations
the other
pitch I would make on this front is that
at the end of the day when we bring in
money to the consumer protection fund
whatever money we bring in over and
above five million dollars
comes back to the general fund anyway so
if we have a a um a big year and we
bring in 10 to 15 million dollars into
that fund which does sometimes happen
it's Flo the extras flowing back to the
general fund anyway but there may be
years where we only bring in a couple
million dollars and so
we don't want to end up in a situation
where
if our typical needs are two and a half
three million dollars
um we don't want to we don't want to
increase those needs on the fund to say
5 million because we're gonna end up
with a shortage in a given given fiscal
year so I think this is a more
sustainable more sensible way to go of
course it's it's ultimately up to you
but this is our proposal to to to move
some of those positions back and that is
resulting in an increase in general
funds
the next increase in general funds again
is related to to the new doj space over
at Granite place
right now the building we're in is a
state-owned building so we don't we
don't pay an annual lease
well yeah we don't pay an annual lease
to a non-state landlord right we do pay
certain expenses to das
while the state may end up buying the
building we're moving into down the road
at the moment the state does not own
that building so we now have a pretty
major lease payment that we haven't had
before so that's contributing to our to
our general fund increase
and then we do have some new permanent
position requests which I'll I'll run
through on the next page and talk about
why we're requesting them so Mr attorney
general what's the lease payment the
but that's the total expenses it's been
a lot of discussion around some of the
different proposals that we saw last
year and now the new lease payments
which appear to be a little higher than
we anticipated that's why we advance the
commissioner of Das to be here to maybe
answer some of those questions but yes I
I believe we can come back to it while
Kathy looks it up but that's one of our
concerns yeah it's
yeah I like I said I believe the total
expenses attributed to doj are about a
million dollars I I want to say our
lease payment
is something less than that but we'll
we'll get is seven to eight hundred
thousand but we'll get the exact numbers
I can also help speak to some of the
increased expenses so because Charlie
and I had a lot of discussions about
that
with legislative leadership before we
all right
so with that I will move to the next
slide which highlights our new permanent
position requests
we've already covered Elder fraud so
Elder fraud is sprinkled throughout here
we have one request for a new general
criminal position
this request comes as a result I think I
talked about this when I was here about
a month ago but this request is
connected to our efforts to expand our
Cold Case unit
two budgets ago the legislature funded
two new Cold Case unit positions
with covid and everything that went on
and a lot of the other things that took
the Department's attention during covid
we didn't make a lot of progress in
standing up those two new positions in
the expanded unit and so in the last
budget one of those positions was
unfunded it was unfunded early in the
budget process when we thought
all agencies were going to have to make
10 cuts amid the governor's original
guidance agencies was cut 10 percent
I think due to the transition and you
know the transition from former Attorney
General McDonald to me that happened in
the middle of the budget process
we never went back and refunded that
position
um before the end of the budget so what
I did during the last biennium is I
moved a different criminal position into
the Cold Case unit because I wanted to
keep us moving on actually standing up a
full-time Cold Case unit this General
criminal position would would basically
backfill that so that's really what this
request is related to I think we
probably never should have unfunded that
Cold Case unit position but it was just
a result of initially thinking we had to
make cuts and then having a leadership
transition in the middle of the budget
process
which resulted in us never going back
and asking to refund that position at
the end of the last budget process
representative McGuire has a question
yes thank you Mr chairman so on the Cold
Case unit
you have a sense when you assign people
to certain cases which ones are the most
promising right so the secondary person
in that unit presumably is working on
the colder of the cold cases right so
they're less likely to
result in prosecution compared to the
first one yes
um I wouldn't necessarily say that
because we are approach a doj as always
is to assign generally to lawyers to to
any case so I we do have a head of the
unit and someone who works for the head
of the unit but I wouldn't necessarily
say it always Stacks up like that that
the the unit Chief is working on the the
most promising cases and the the second
in command is working on the coldest of
cases
in the Cold Case unit I should also say
there is a lot of work that happens just
to continue to assess what cases
um have good prospects for getting less
cold and one of the things we're trying
to do right now is do a fresh assessment
of of every case or going through that
exercise be because
these are sort of a case is a living
breathing
thing you know it's there's always
changing you can get new information at
any time that might change your outlook
on a case and so constant reassessment
okay but is that okay is that the least
payment or is that just everything
that's what we're paying
we used to pay 45. once again
like 71 in the 90s we had budgeted 97. I
see but we're going to be paying uh okay
yes okay so our not to interrupt you sir
representative Griffin has a question oh
absolutely sorry about that
sure thank you attorney for taking it
um I just want to understand this isn't
open above the budget you've already put
these in the budget
these positions correct yeah these are
these are in the budget we're just
highlighting that these are new position
all right so just to quickly go back to
the the least question I think our our
budgeted lease payment is which would be
made to to das because Das makes the
payment then to the landlord is one
million two hundred thirty six thousand
seven hundred thirty eight dollars in
fiscal year 24 and 1 million two hundred
and twenty one thousand six hundred
sixty three dollars in fiscal year
twenty five
so I'm forgetting what the total payment
of the landlord is but I believe it's
it's somewhere between 1.5 and 2 million
but I think Charlie would be able to
answer that exactly representative evil
yeah
that was going to be my question because
I remember when you folks were going to
move over there you were thinking you
could put some other agency type folks
in is that happening or you're still in
anticipating that there are plans to do
that and I know I know Das is working on
that and
we're have we're in those conversations
too because we all want to try to make
sure that we um are able to do that with
the money that was budgeted while not
you know
cutting any uh what I'll call A A very
important need of of the doj so
now these are significant lease payments
there was some discussion at one point
that the state would have an option to
buy this property uh those lease
payments going towards that ultimate
possible purchase or
so the state's option to buy the
around a year again I want to be careful
because I'm now I'm going to get into
details that I don't have exactly off
top of my head but around a year
the lease payments we make
I don't think that the first year's
lease payment is is a credit to the the
option but
okay yeah no but I think that's why the
option kicks in after only a year
because we wouldn't necessarily want to
pay 10 years worth of lease payments and
then buy the building
Melissa and Mike could you get some more
information on that uh for the division
from the commissioner
that would be great I representative
McGuire has a question yes thank you you
pay an internal lease kind of payment on
this building here yes yes for this year
I mean yep so what is that
budget imprint
sorry we're budgeted for 97
um yeah 97 134. all right so next to
nothing by comparison yes I think it's
oh okay
so you were on the wrong line or
right 330. but still it's a quadrupling
right yeah
yeah it's it's it's a big increase I I
mean we can
um
so the next position Enviro
Environmental Protection attorney so
this is
um
I would say this is our request but it
is also a request of the Department of
Environmental Services there's a few
things going on here that have led to to
this request
the first is that
the Environmental Protection Bureau
represents the Department of
Environmental Services so they provide
client counseling to the Department of
Environmental Services they defend the
Department of Environmental Services if
they're sued but they also are the ones
who bring enforcement actions in court
that arise out of of Des investigations
that Bureau now also represents the
department of energy so while it's
called the Environmental Protection
Bureau the new Department of energy is
is a new client for that Bureau so that
that is added to the workload of that
Bureau there is also additional work
projects that are being funded through
through arpa funds there's a whole
category of arpa funds that are all for
environmental projects and so
um DES in conversation with our
Environmental Protection Bureau asked
for a new attorney position and that's
that's what's that's where this request
comes from that's the reasoning for the
request
and then there's also sorry do you have
a question representative
yes representative Sweeney thank you
thank you chairman thank you general for
being here so you mentioned energy and
Des share that attorney
I would imagine there'd be a number of
issues with energy being on one side and
Des being on the other
with that attorney for so there's is
there a team of attorneys that are
shared or is it just the one yeah
there's I would say they share the
entire team okay this new attorney is is
it really just as a result of the
increased overall workload from a new
Department a new client that the bureau
has but yeah if there were ever if there
ever were an issue that Des needed
representation on and they were on the
opposite side of the Department of
energy say in a proceeding before the
puc we would we would either wall off
attorneys within the bureau we might
also bring in a civil litigation like an
attorney from a different Bureau to
represent one or the other to make sure
that there is there are good walls in
place thank you yep that's
representative evil what are the
arpa-funded environmental projects
so I I don't off the top of my head I
don't know exactly what those projects
are but I do know that there were there
was a significant component of arpa
funds that were
were
designated for
environmental type projects so when when
the state got its whole pot of arpa
funds there were some funds that could
be used for basically anything because
they were Revenue replacement funds
there were some funds that could only be
used for specific purposes and there
were a couple of different categories
that were environmental related so the
state got
um I'm forgetting the amount of money I
think it was at least 100 million
dollars for for those those types of
projects and Des you know got permission
to accept and expend those those funds
but
the next uh attorney position is that we
requested as a new civil litigation
attorney so we
we have seen a big increase in in the
load on our civil litigation unit that
has been reflected in our requests that
we've brought to the fiscal committee
for for litigation funds
uh up until a couple years ago the
typical amount that we would request
from fiscal was was two to three million
dollars each fiscal year
in this particular fiscal year we we
requested over seven million dollars now
we're hoping not to spend all of that
but that was our estimated request so we
have seen just a big increase in the
workload on our civil litigation unit
we have part of the reason for the
request of litigation funds increasing
is because we also have vacancies in
that unit right now we have nine total
lawyers in that unit two of the
positions are vacant
we're about to fill one of them so we're
about to be down to one vacancy and then
we've asked for one additional lawyer
because I think if we could get up to 10
full-time lawyers in that unit that
would really help part of the increase
in the litigation fund I do think is
temporary because it's related to a
couple of really big cases we're working
on right now for HHS but overall based
on my general assessment of the of the
litigation landscape I think I think it
makes sense to add an attorney to that
unit
so are these labor related mostly or
what civil
so I mean fraud would be criminal right
yeah yeah so civil litigation is when
the state gets sued so when we're
defending that's what that unit does
every now and then they'll assist other
bureaus with uh say enforcement actions
more proactive enforcement actions but
the civil litigation unit is the unit
that that defends the state
right why don't we skip ahead to the
medical examiners yes okay
so the the new assistant Deputy medical
examiner positions
are
what we're doing here is taking
positions or not positions but taking
individuals so right now we have 10
assistant Deputy medical examiners
but they are or is it 12. yeah right now
we have 12 assistant Deputy medical
examiners but they are contractors so
I've had a lot of discussion about this
with our chief medical examiner we
thought about doing it in the last
biennium we decided not to but after
more discussion what we're proposing in
this budget is to create
10 full-time positions so to make these
Deputy medical examiners full-time
employees as opposed to contractors we
expect this is going to be cost neutral
or if anything actually save a little
bit of money but they're
I have a on the next slide if you'd like
me to skip to it there are a few reasons
the first is that the IRS over the years
has at various times raised concerns
with with the structure
that we use for our assistant Deputy
medical examiners they have raised
questions as to whether they're really
independent contractors because in many
ways they do function like employees
and while they've never
formally made a finding against us
that could change at some point and so
that that's one reason we think it makes
sense to just make the change
it's so it also can be more difficult to
manage individuals who essentially are
working for the state but aren't
employers they're all individual
contractors they're not you know we
can't
we can't Implement employment policies
that they're really bound to we can
negotiate what's in their contracts but
you have to do that over and over again
and so that that's an administrative
burden and can get kind of cumbersome
we also sometimes struggle with coverage
in different parts of the state and if
we had
10 assistant Deputy medical examiners
who were state employees it would be
easier for us to say look you're going
to cover Cheshire for the next couple
months because we're short there or we
have a vacancy up in the North Country
you're just you're going to cover the
North Country it's harder to do that
when you have contractors who really try
to negotiate in their contracts that
they're only going to cover cover
certain areas so that that would be
helpful to us and then
when there are 10 independent or when
they're multiple independent contractors
they compete with each other right
they're not
necessarily bound to each other they're
they're independent entities and so
unifying this function
under the office of the chief medical
examiner we think would be would be a
good move it would just create for more
coordination and cohesion
representative Ebel has a question for
you could could you tell me what the
what the qualifications are to be a
medical exam a deputy medical examiner
do you have to be a doctor or no no so
Deputy medical I mean I suppose you
could be a doctor if say you didn't want
to practice medicine anymore and you
wanted to do this but the deputy medical
examiners and
are another way to think of them is is
sort of the investigators for the chief
medical examiner so it's the chief
medical examiner and the deputy chief
medical examiner who ultimately do
autopsies and make determinations on
cause of death the assistant Deputy
medical examiners will go out to a scene
so if you have if you have a car car
crash a tragic fatal car crash where
there's a death don't go out to the
scene they'll look at the information
they'll they'll look at the body they'll
they'll collect what's there they will
report that back to the chief Deputy
medical examiner and then if if there is
an autopsy when that happens the medical
examiner will use that information
that's been collected to make their
determination so you don't have to be a
doctor I don't I apologize I don't know
off the top I had exactly what the
qualifications are but also they've
never been employees so we haven't had
you know a posting with qualifications
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so we only have I think is it
100 homicides or something like that so
is there enough work for 10 people so
the the medical the assistant Deputy
medical examiners don't just work on
homicides they they work on on any death
not necessarily if we don't if there is
not every death but there's a much
broader category of deaths that they
work on than homicides if a death is
unexpected
um or there's uh something about it that
makes us think we need to at least check
it out and gather information those are
the deaths the deaths they work on so
it's a much broader category than just
the homicides is it is it um 10 because
there's one per County
that's the reason we picked 10 we
witness it's not necessarily one in each
County because the bigger counties need
more right but that's that's why we took
it down from 12 to 10 just we thought we
we thought we could make it work based
on conversation with with 10 especially
if they're full-time employees
representative Schultz has a question
thank you Mr chair
um I've heard that there is a backlog in
rape kit processing I'd imagine
this office would have some role in that
and I'm wondering if there still is a
backlog or if that is a myth and same on
I know during the um
Crux of the opioid crisis we had a
backlog and autopsies too and
determinations of death
um how are those two situations
thank you for the question so on the
rape kits the the office of the chief
medical examiner actually does not have
a role in in those
um that's the state lab
I we have been involved in conversations
regarding that though and and and I've
talked to the commissioner's safety
about this we're taking steps to address
that backlog I don't know if I can tell
you today that there is no backlog but I
can tell significant progress has been
made and we are very aware of that issue
and we're we're taking steps to ensure
that we eliminate the backlog and that
it doesn't recur we've had a lot of
conversations with the Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence about the
issue too and
they are aware of the steps we're taking
everybody's working on working on that
um
as to autopsies I think during
I wouldn't say there's necessarily a um
a backlog on on autopsies because those
have to get done you know within a
certain period of time but cause of
death determinations do take some time I
during covid those did get somewhat
backed up we've made a lot of progress
on that one of the issues we're dealing
with right now is we we came to the
legislature probably a couple of
bienniums ago to get a third medical
examiner position so we're budgeted for
a chief medical examiner a deputy chief
medical examiner and then an associate
medical examiner that associate medical
examiner position has been vacant for a
couple of years so we that is added to
our struggle but we we are certainly
taking every step we can to at least
reduce any backlog and cause of death
and final cause of death determinations
often there's an initial determination
that's made in an initial death
certificate that is issued so that next
of kin can take the steps necessary but
the medical examiner can't make a final
cause of death determination until they
have all all the information in and
until they have the ability to look at
all that information make a formal final
finding so we're we're working on that
yep
all right
would you like me to go through the
positions we skipped or just move move
forward
the new support staff I can just run
through those real quick
yeah very quickly we're getting a little
short on time but I think you're an
important department so if we go over
that's okay too okay so I'll be really
quick so the First new support staff
position which is by far the most
important I would say is a human
resources coordinator we don't have a
lot of people assume we have this but in
the Department of Justice we don't have
an HR officer our chief of staff who is
a lawyer has sort of functioned that way
it's not really best practice I it would
be good I think to have a non-lawyer HR
officer within the office so that that's
our first request as a new position
we're also requesting a new grants
manager position or I think this is this
is yeah converting this from part-time
to full-time so it's kind of half of a
new position uh
on the last slide I'll hit really
quickly I'll talk about all the grand
money we bring in but
we're doing more and more of that and so
it'd be helpful to have have that
position be converted to full time
a victim Witness Program specialist
that that position Works in our office
of victim witness assistance works with
victims of crime
that office is doing a lot more work
with stakeholders around the state to do
educational programming to put on
seminars
to really help train
folks in the counties County victim
witness Advocates and others on best
practices for assisting victims of crime
it'd be helpful to have an additional
program specialist to do that work
a new civil paralegal and civil Legal
Assistant in the civil litigation unit
that's really to support what I talked
about earlier the additional load on the
civil litigation unit there's a lot of
work that you don't have to have lawyers
do a Paralegal and a legal assistant can
can do a lot of great work to help the
lawyers and it's they're it's also
cheaper so we're proposing those two new
positions to help support the additional
civil litigation backlog and then we've
already talked about the Elder fraud
investigative paralegal so those are
so I'm going to skip ahead
and I'll run through this quickly
because I think I've talked about it but
I'm going to skip ahead to slide 10.
just to give you a couple of numbers on
the need for additional support for the
elder abuse and financial exploitation
unit
one in ten older adults are victimized
of these incidents are reported that's
that's incredibly low it's among the
worst numbers we have for people who are
victims of some type of crime
part of the reason for that uh there are
various reasons why people don't report
one is that it's embarrassing right
whenever you're a victim but two when
you don't feel like there's a place to
report where something's going to happen
the embarrassment of reporting is not
outweighed by the desire to see
accountability and see some see
consequences because there isn't a
enough of a function in the state to to
investigate and prosecute these crimes
so that's part of the reason we're we're
looking for more resources here
the next slide also kind of highlights
why we're seeing increased victimization
of older adults especially in the
financial Arena
it's just a financial reality that that
baby boomers so people in the age of say
58 to 75 right now have have more assets
than than the generation coming up
uh
just to kind of put it bluntly in plain
speaking terms we're seeing kids
victimize their parents right or kids
victimize an older relative their Uncle
um their aunt uh because they have
assets and they're looking to to tap
into those assets so that's that's also
increasing that that's what's leading to
the increase in victimization and then
just some numbers here there are various
ways that we get reports and tips on
on instances of elder abuse the most
reliable source by far our law
enforcement referrals and as you'll see
here between the 27
2017-2018 time frame and the 2021-2022
time frame those referrals increased
from 758
total in that time frame to 1032 in the
most recent time frame so we're seeing
these numbers go up I still think that
that those numbers are low part of what
this unit does and will be able to do
better with expanded resources is
educate law enforcement agencies on when
they need to be reporting to our elder
abuse and financial exploitation unit
right recognizing that this crime was a
result of an attempt to victimize an
older person and warrants reporting to
to that unit so education I think will
also lead to reports going up I think
there's just a lot going on that we're
not seeing and that in many ways is half
the battle is at least knowing about
what's happening
the last couple of
points I just want to hit
and these are two positions that we are
requesting
that would be over and above what's
already in our budget the first is a new
victim witness specialist
I talked about this position with the
governor's office and it was sort of a
last minute point that I raised which
was partly on me it didn't make it into
the budget but what we did not
appreciate that I should have
appreciated is that expanding the
capacity within our elder abuse and
financial exploitation unit will also
expand
the workload on our victim witness
Specialists we right now in our office
of victim witness assistants only have I
think three victim witness Specialists
who are full-time dedicated to that work
the head of our office is also a victim
witness specialist so she does that work
we've been able to get by with that we
try to be very efficient but I think
expanding the capacity that we've talked
about in our elder abuse and financial
exploitation unit
would result in us really needing an
additional victim witness specialist to
help support that work right now that
unit only
has the only has access to
some of the capacity of one victim
witness specialist and increasing the
the need for a victim specialist in that
unit I think really
makes it so that we need we need that
new position so that's the reason for
that request
uh it's uh from the division about
adding this specialist witness
specialist
I am assuming that oh representative
McGuire
yeah I I think it makes more sense than
the Cold Case person so I would switch
from one to the other
although if you've lost someone and like
to get closure a Cold Case specialist is
very important but
um yeah but I don't think the volume of
cases
is anywhere near the same right it's
I would say the volume is not the same
but the cases aren't created equally
right the cold cases are our most
difficult cases by Nature that they're
cold so they they take a lot of work
just to try to get them to to not be
Representatives
I was under the assumption that HHS had
an investigations unit into Elder issues
is that just something completely off
the radar not
what you're talking about so that yeah
they have a bureau of elderly and Adult
Services we do get referrals from them
but they do not do criminal
investigations of so if if we're going
to try to bring criminal cases to really
impose consequences that I think get the
maximum deterrence that's not what HHS
does
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you again general for
being here take the questions for the
elder abuse and financial cases when the
when it's not a family member or if it's
out of state or out of country source
that is pulling the funds or scamming
the individuals
what's the success rate on being able to
prosecute those cases and retrieving
recovering the the funds that were
stolen
that's a good question so I don't have I
can see if I can get you an answer on
that like what the success rate is
um you know if it's a if it's an out of
country Source I mean that that's
difficult right being able to identify
the perpetrator those aren't the cases
though that we're most concerned with to
be honest I would say I'm most concerned
with instances where the victim knows
the person that's that's exploiting them
right we also see things like a
grandparent scam where it is a total
stranger who will call up call up a
person and say your grandson's been
arrested
I need ten thousand dollars to bail him
out of jail I'll stop by your house in
two hours can you have the cash ready
you know they stop by
they take the cash never to be heard
from again those are the types of things
we're seeing that are that are really
what we're looking to address we of
course have instances where someone is
ex you know victimized by by an out of
country perpetrator and I would imagine
the success rate on that to be honest is
pretty low because those are difficult
but that's not the the bulk of of what
we're trying to address with these
additional resources
yeah
so let's just see if we can get to a
conclusion on your additional request
here yeah is that your only ask I know
there's a couple of things in House Bill
too that we'd like to discuss if we have
the time but is this your only
additional ask from the governor's
budget the the only other additional ask
and I would say the victim witness
specialist is much more important but I
wanted to point out the the other piece
is that there was an additional attorney
request in the transportation
construction Bureau and the funding was
budgeted in the transport the department
of transportation's budget the position
was not put into the department of
Justice's budget so
um it was an ask that we made in the
governor's phase the governor did not
approve it the position but he did
approve the the funding and so
you know I we put that in our
presentation to to point that out I
think there was potentially a
misunderstanding as to whether maybe
there were two different attorneys
attorney positions being requested but
that was our one other additional ask
was to actually create that that
position because the funding is there
the position isn't there so my my advice
would be switching into my advice hat we
should probably either create the
position or cut the funding but having
the funding without the position is is
probably not where we want to be
representative McGuire has a question
yes thank you how many of your 166
employees are vacant right now are
vacant yeah I I believe we have
13 vacancies in our 166 permanent
employees I believe it's eight attorneys
and five support staff
it may be an important time a question
for Kathy we see these updates
occasionally in fiscal but the amount of
money that the Department of Justice has
been successful in returning to the
yeah I wanted to leave you with this so
that's a perfect question
so the last slide we outline are
recoveries for 2021 and 2022
um the department has recovered and
deposited to the general fund
approximately 126.7 million dollars
Grant funds managed this isn't really a
recovery I would say but it it is we do
the work to go out and apply for and get
the grants that we manage so about 138
million dollars in Grant funds managed
the 52.7 million dollars in opioid
settlement funds that's another recovery
it doesn't go into the general fund it
goes into the opioid abatement trust
fund but so we've listed that separately
the Environmental Protection Bureau has
had 6.8 million dollars in in recoveries
into
um either into the bureau or fund funds
other than the general funder or the uh
the opioid abatement trust fund
um
the the Consumer Protection Bureau has
recovered 2.7 million dollars on behalf
of consumers those don't that money
doesn't come to the state that they take
it in they give it directly back to the
consumers that were affected and then
this is an area which I think there's a
fair amount of room for growth but we've
we've recovered in those two years about
444 000 in debt recoveries debt recovery
on behalf of the state
um so that that that is a snapshot I
think of what what the office brings in
I would respectfully submit that I think
this
given all of the work the office does
the fact that the office generally
brings in more than it spends I think
makes the Department of Justice
um a pretty good bargain for the State
of New Hampshire because we not only
provide a lot of service we also recover
a lot on behalf of the state
so with that with the division field
comfortable in supporting the victim
witness Specialist or
looks like there's a lot of flexibility
built into the position as you describe
it so you can use it in not I mean we
talked a lot about the elder abuse cases
but if the time wasn't needed for that
it looks like there are other ways in
which it would be really beneficial to
have that individual So speaking for
myself I would support that addition
further representative McGuire yeah okay
can we add somebody in this recovery
[Laughter]
yeah I would say I mean that that is a
result of work of a lot of different
lawyers within the office I I think
that
on that point representative I think it
is important to highlight that while we
have various bureaus and units within
the office the lawyers and the staff
usually end up working in various
different parts of the office at any
given time so we don't have very many
people who are just siled in one area
they may focus in one area that area
might be their specialty but they do
various things one example going back to
environmental our environmental Bureau
is the Bureau that also represents the
judicial branch most of the time so
people really
do work across disciplines and they all
they all pitch in so these recoveries
that the office brings in really are a
result of of work across the office
obviously there are some bureaus that
get more recoveries than others the
homicide unit is not typically
recovering money on behalf of the state
but anytime I think the office gets an
additional resource it enhances our
ability to get recoveries on behalf of
the state because we can be flexible we
can shift work around and we can focus
on places where we can get good results
representative evil are you involved in
some
at this point on behalf of the state
environmentally or otherwise
we are we are involved in in some major
cases also some major investigations
often if we're
um if we are undertaking an
investigation we won't actually end up
suing we'll settle before we we Sue but
we we do have some big cases probably
the biggest is the pfas case against 3M
and a couple of other parties yep
that any recovery in that case is is
quite a ways off but we are pretty
confident that we will eventually get a
big recovery out of that case
and there are various others where we
expect to get recoveries in the millions
now there are some issues in House Bill
2 which affect you folks who really like
to quickly jump to those
Melissa Mike do you have the specific
ones I think we had start off maybe 19.
there's a Department of Justice
section 19 is the first one and that's
on page
each
that's okay that's good that way we're
what is this oh this is the market
factors well I guess we checked that one
off yesterday when we slid over it but I
there's also 268 through 279.
foreign
yeah we we don't really have any at
least that we're doj requests there's
really no money requests in hb2 the the
proposed raise that the governor
included in the budget does affect our
Market anchors
so you'll I forget what section that is
in hp2 but that will
yeah so on page 73
the market anchors so kind of the salary
ranges for our attorneys did go up but
that is just what we're legally allowed
to pay attorneys what the money that's
included in our budget for salaries is
really what matters so I I wouldn't
that affects us but it wasn't a request
we put into hb2 that's tied to I think
the the
the governor's proposed raises for state
employees which
will shift or not based on what you all
decide on that issue
so in hb2 the governor had an
appropriation of 21 million dollars for
the uh purchase or lease of granite
places that are reasonable number
Charlie or
are we going to need to
exceed that or you're welcome to take
you can sit Charlie says right now use
that mic right there if you'd like
Charlie
here I apologize for stealing your mic
um yes it's a reasonable number that's
the number we uh we gave the the least
number has a purchase price in it which
is the which is uh roughly 15 million
dollars plus the
um unrepaid cost of the Fed Up So the
landlord is doing a significant fit up
on the space and so that would add
another 6 million
so that's item 75 on page 31.
and I know there are weird rumors
floating around the state house but we
wouldn't get addressed yeah we would be
buying
one Tower
that is the South Tower which is
um the unoccupied portion today that's
being fit up there are some people
who've said oh I heard we're buying both
Towers including the one that judicial
branch is in and that's not the case
are there any questions or at least not
with that money we're not commissioner
Arling house on a matter representative
evil
just a real uh basic question you've
analyzed the uh
fiscal uh background of this and you've
decided purchasing it is makes more
sense than Leasing
oh yeah it's not a great lease
um yeah I mean if we're gonna we're
gonna have people in this building for
for 20 years we should buy it not lease
it and the obstacle to that is always
the cost I mean we've not done an
inspection of any you know if you think
about like a like a home inspection and
and if you really want to get into
detail we can tell you what's entailed
and then that's why Karen's here but um
um we would do we would spend a
significant amount of money over the
next few months actually assuming this
looks like it's going forward and that
you guys don't just excise it from your
bill
um and you know look in detail at all of
the systems and Etc of the building you
know the equivalent of a home inspection
but basically somebody knows what
they're doing gets in the HVAC system
and all of that kind of thing
further question
we figured out
um other agencies or state employees
you're thinking we'll move over there to
join in with doj we we've had a lot of
discussion internally about that and and
exactly what that looks like is is
uncertain from the standpoint what we're
busy cataloging everybody who wants to
move somewhere for some reason is you
know losing their lease space or or you
know rearrange this office or there's
construction going on here or
construction going on there and the some
of the moving pieces of that are you
know where exactly are we
for example on the annex Renault
um and what what movement does that
entail
um
is the state really going to buy the
building on Hall Street where Department
of Education would go or not
um if that happens what would be the the
timeline on the Lonergan renovation for
example and how all of those things work
and we actually I think
I think at two o'clock-ish I have a
space yeah I have a space planning
meeting they'll talk about some of those
things but I I think you know big
picture of the building is about 100 000
square feet so
um doj has about two and a half floors
so call it maybe 65 000 square feet
which leaves about 35 000. we ideally
wouldn't like to move people in who
don't need renovation
because that's you know easier
a lot
and cheaper representative McGuire has a
question thank you so uh when would the
transfer the purchase take place and
would their lease payment decline back
to the 300 000 range afterwards well
they they probably wouldn't decline back
to the 300 000 range afterwards because
there's a lot of costs that would have
to be entailed and I don't know I'm
going to actually ask Karen to come up
and join me
um because I'm going to say something
stupid
um
but I think
okay we can oh look at that
um
I don't think we've actually figured
that out because the purchase would be
let's just say House Bill 2 let's say
the budget you know happens and there
are no unfortunate tragic accidents and
we have a budget on July 1st we would
then start the process of uh negotiating
and I don't think we can buy before
completed by it's like a 12-month window
I think or eight eight or ten month
window maybe so so doj would almost
certainly move in in the um in the late
summer
and then we think
um in the late summer you know how
construction is
um and then
um
you know then we would buy the building
and and let's say that all went well at
a minimum the first fiscal year is is
you know the new price and the second
fiscal year
um
you know we'd have to look at because
there's it's still a significantly more
expensive building than the building
they're in and the building they're in
the costs
by the way there's a the you know why
Kathy and I have different numbers is
what do J pays and what the building uh
so when we started assigning costs to
building somehow accidentally doj
escaped uh costs being assigned to them
and they're paid out of the general fund
um and um and that would not be the case
in the future and so the cost of the
building let's say for example we didn't
move them and we didn't build a parking
garage and they stayed in in the old
Bank building
the cost would go up to pretty close to
a half a million dollars I think it
would have been foreign change in the
first year five and changed in the
second and
um
and so a lot of the costs are going up
and and some of that is based on on how
we allocate centralized costs today and
the centralized costs allocated of that
building would be dramatically larger
so you don't think we can go below the
1.2 million in the second year
I don't
you know what give me a give me a few
weeks to get back to you on that and I I
want to say no our deadline is next
Friday not this Friday next Friday oh
like the the 17th
um Let Me Take A let me take a crack at
that about the 17th but I think probably
not
yes follow-up yeah I just wondered how
the fit up was going
well and I see a Karen here that can
answer it's progressing
um if you were to visit the site it
would look different than it did you
know a month or two ago for sure
um there are some as as we're seeing
everywhere some lead times on the more
expensive pieces of equipment and things
that we're getting but walls are going
up and electricals going in and things
like that so it's it's progressing and
seeing no further questions on granite
place
I guess you're off the hook at least for
thank you all right are there further
questions for the attorney general or
Kathy on budget I guess representative
Sweeney thank you very much thank you
again for indulging us I just have one
request for information for the 10
medical examiners yep can you put
together what you would project the
average caseload for each one and how
much time it takes per case for them
just I think that's a missing piece of
yep that that should be
doable given that they're already
working on yes right so yeah we can
provide that absolutely great thank you
Mr Hoffman any other issues that
have hit your radar
that while we have the Attorney General
here that we should discuss
uh not off the top of my head but when I
call Kathy she's very good at getting us
information so
another person that can't retire so nope
she just got reappointed for another
five-year term so we're expecting we're
expecting her to fulfill that I guess
we're safe for at least another five
on the medical Deputy medical exam
there's a Hot Topic I guess today so
there's so much uh trouble filling jobs
you're feeling like you'll be able to
fill them even though you're switching
from independent contractors to
it's a great question representative and
I have had that conversation with our
chief medical examiner and deputy chief
medical examiner a lot they feel
confident and I think we feel confident
I mean we already have a pool of people
who are who are acting as independent
contractors they feel pretty confident
we can we can fill these positions
because they're again they're not
they're not medical doctors so they
don't come from that really exclusive
pool that the medical examiners come
from so we do feel confident can never
so I guess all we're really looking for
is uh the answers to representative
Sweeney's questions on the medical
examiners and who will make a decision
on your victim witness specialist that
will be on our list to either check off
or decline but okay I think other than
that we should be all set with the
attorney general's office
uh Mr Hoffman there's also that
Transportation Bureau attorney that's
budget
so it needs to be authorized if you
choose to
you know so we'll we'll straighten that
language out as long as the dot doesn't
assign it back to you to pay for it
yeah exactly yeah the money will be in
well thank you sir and Kathy thanks
thank you very much questions I guess
we're good
so we do have the Human Rights
Commission which is an administratively
attached to the Attorney General's
office so apologize for our little delay
here
foreign
we're just going to take a very short
break for the everyone get reorganized
here
picture
foreign
information
[Music]
today
yes
um
okay now we have the Human Rights
Commission
or the New Hampshire commission for
human rights and the directors here if
you could state your name for the record
please and I think we have your spelling
in the package it this is at the back of
the Attorney General's package for those
of you that are looking and Kathy's here
to help with any Financial questions
welcome good morning thank you yes our
significantly smaller slides are at the
back of the Department of Justice
information good morning everyone my
name is Ani Malachi I am the executive
director for the New Hampshire
commission for human rights the
commission was established in 1965 by
RSA
354-a for the purpose of eliminating
discrimination in the areas of
employment housing public accommodations
and as of 2019
K-12 public education which means
charter schools and public academies are
included in that as well
the commission is comprised of seven
volunteer Commissioners who provide
oversight and make decisions on charges
of discrimination and those
Commissioners are appointed by the
governor and confirmed by the executive
Council
and um oh well that's the next part and
then they survey a five-year term
um what is it that the commission does
we have the power to receive on uh
receive to investigate and pass upon
complaints of illegal discrimination and
to engage in research education and
community outreach designed to prevent
discrimination in addition to the
authority vested in the commission by
RSA 354-a to enforce New Hampshire's
laws against discrimination the
commission also Partners currently with
the U.S equal opportunity equal
employment opportunity commission or as
I'll refer to it here as the EEOC to
enforce federal laws
prohibiting discrimination and
employment as well if you turn over to
the next page you'll see the current
commission organization
below me is one assistant director and
there's an administrative assistant
position which is currently unfunded we
have a part-time secretary who is
providing some of those Services
currently and for the enforcement staff
we have five full-time investigators and
we have one full-time intake person and
we have a part-time intake position that
is currently unfunded and there is a
part-time paralegal position which we
have just recently filled
on the next page our numbers so this
chart is really just an aggregate over
the past couple of years that will show
you and we go from federal fiscal year
so from October to September excuse me
um just an aggregate on the number of
charges filed per month the number of
charges closed full Federal Credit means
that we may have charges uh or a case
that's opened where
the individual will maybe they remove it
or maybe it's something that needs to be
forwarded to the EEOC for investigation
so we would get an intake credit for
that and it wouldn't be a full
um we we get paid in reimbursement from
the EEOC so it wouldn't be a full
reimbursement specifically just an
intake
and then next to that category there's a
listing of the number of state only
charges so those would be because our
partnership or work sharing agreement
right now is with the EEOC they only
deal with employment so if it's in any
of the other areas like public
accommodation education or housing those
are not covered by the EEOC so those
cases would be considered state only or
if it is an employment case and the
number of employees is below the
threshold for the federal government
which is 14 then that would be
considered a state-only case as well and
then the last column are the unassigned
charges so those are charges that have
come in those are cases that have been
opened those are cases that are not
assigned to the five investigators that
we currently have to begin
investigations
the next page what we need
so our prioritized needs for the
upcoming budget the state fiscal year 24
and 25. so the governor's budget has
included reinstatement of funds for the
administrative assistant for us which is
great he is also provided finances for
us to add three additional three of the
four additional investigators that we
are requesting and then funded costs for
a move to a new location which is to be
determined because we don't know where
we're going yet our lease ends at the
end of October of this year and there is
not an opportunity to extend currently
the building is up for sale but I'm not
aware that it is under a purchase sale
agreement at this moment but we've
already outgrown it with just the staff
that we have and so we would certainly
need to find a new location
once these additional staff members the
three additional
investigators is hopefully approved by
you wonderful people and uh and then of
course he included funding for our DOT
shared costs so I think I well there
were the remaining needs was one
additional
um investigator which was requested the
initial request and the budget I put
forth was for four
um investigators and we got three so we
are very happy with that just stating
these are the remaining needs that are
on the table as it were and to convert
the part-time paralegal and part-time
secretary positions to full-time with
the increase or just the number of
charges that we have there's more than
enough work for the paralegal to be able
to do on a full-time basis and then
to have that additional secretary or not
additional but to have that secretary
there full-time instead of Simply
part-time there are great many other
items that that person can do to assist
in the office more so than just
answering the phones
um and I think that's it so that is
everything that I have for you right now
I'm certainly willing to answer in uh
any questions uh just be gentle
[Laughter]
representative Griffin
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question could you go and do the
unassigned what what a little a little
more depth into what makes a case
unassigned
and how that fits into the picture
certainly thank you representative
Griffin for the question
um so when a case uh when a person comes
to us and makes a charge of
discrimination they encounter our intake
coordinator and that person will
um we we do normally draft the charge
for the individual but we've also
created a toolkit to allow an individual
to draft their own charges
um so the intake person would just look
over everything making sure all of the
elements are there and making sure
certainly in that intake process that
initially they're in the right place so
someone could have a wages and hours
issue that does not have an element of
discrimination so we would listen
carefully but then refer them to labor
because wages in hours is not what we do
however there could be a situation where
it's wages and hours based on
discrimination so we would take that
into consideration uh draft that charge
or help the complainant draft charge and
then move forward with that
once a charge is drafted and notarized
so there has to be notaries and we do
have those in our office so people can
come to us and there's no fee they don't
pay us for anything that we do for them
so everything we do is a civil service
once that charge is notarized then a
copy of that information goes to the
responding party so whether it's a
business whether it's a store or a an
amusement park if it's a place of public
accommodation or a school or a housing
facility that information goes out and
then hopefully that respondent will
respond to us
customarily what happens is the large
percentage of individuals that file a
charge with us are what we call
unrepresented or Pro Se meaning they
don't have an attorney which you do not
have to have to go through our process
however the large majority of
respondents that respond to the charges
are represented again you don't have to
have one either way
we have sometimes had we do have
complainants that are represented and
respondents that are unrepresented in
the same case
once that information is sent to the
respondent and they will send their
answer in to the charge
then that information goes into a file
and it is there for unassigned because
it is waiting to be assigned to one of
those of you looking for this in the
budgets on 309.
like the follow along represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming so let's uh look at the chart on
page 21.
um
so filed are people coming in the door
right with a brand new case
I'm guessing right and closed is the
number who are all done correct right
and and
um unassigned is is the number waiting
wouldn't because there were more let's
just look at October there were more
there were nine more closed than came in
so shouldn't the unassigned go down
rather than up
this is an aggregate so it's not the
exact number that came in in that month
as open in the exact number that was
closed that month so give me just one
so for example let's take October of
last year similar
situation so if you left that first
number is filed which is 16 and made
closed 14. the full credit was 14
because that was the number that we
closed we didn't have any state only and
so that unassigned number is 254 from
October of last year the following month
it went down to 232 so to answer your
question yes it would this is not an
exact
October information it's an aggregate
between 2021 fiscal year 21 and 22.
okay so this is two Octobers
yes okay you is averaged okay well why
don't we look at
um
but over time it seems like you're
closing more cases than are coming in if
you look at the very bottom there uh 193
came in
276 got closed right so you're getting
you're getting a head right in some
sense the the backlog is going down is
that correct yes and uh to add to that
we have had staff turnover so there are
times where I've had two investigators
only so we don't tell people not to call
so charges are still opened cases are
still coming in and those two
investigators are moving their case long
case load along as best they can and
I've had a situation with just those two
investigators where I didn't have an
intake coordinator
so all of the things have to continue
going it's just that it's taking longer
for some of those things which is why
I've requested more staff
can you provide the
rather than the average number the
actual month by month for the two years
um I can I could it may be better to
email that I can email you a chart
similar to this yeah that'd be great
okay
um because just in general it seems to
me that if you're closing 70 80 more
cases than your opening
the backlog over time should be going
declining
right and so so like today should be
much less than a year ago
so
not really okay only because yes in
theory that would work but that would
mean that the number is static that
would mean that we wouldn't be taking in
any more charges so if you're cover if
you're if you're closing 25 or more
cases per month then yes over maybe a
year you would eradicate that backlog
right however if you are still opening
cases which we are it could be 10 one
month it could be 20 another month it
there's no particular number then those
that number that is a sign that is
unassigned is going to continue to go up
even though with the five they are
moving through their cases more
efficiently they are um they're moving
through their cases more efficiently but
it doesn't stop the number of of charges
that are coming in does that make sense
right but the number coming in is under
filed here right 193. correct correct
and so
and the number closed 275 significantly
more
right so I'm not saying unassigned will
go to zero but just be 70 less or
something than it was a year ago it it
will however with more hands you are
assigning more cases to potentially have
more cases closed sure yes
yes so for example um January of this
year we filed there were 23 cases that
were filed so I'm reading from my notes
here okay sure I apologize so there were
23 cases that were filed there were 19
cases that were closed we got full
credit for 17 of the 19. two of them we
got an intake credit from the EEOC which
left our unassigned at 242.
however
the next month we took in 16 so in
February last month we took in 16 cases
so right there you're already not you
haven't closed as many as you've taken
in that's right so there are some months
that you might close more than because
we're moving into the into the waiting
the pending cases and there are cases
where you close the same amount so the
pending has not been touched there are
times where you close less than for
whatever reason and you've now added to
the pending
so yes it will eventually decrease but
the amount of time that would take
without knowing how many you're going to
have come in how many you're going to
have leave how many staff members you
yeah
let me try one more different slightly
different way yeah thank you if if the
number being closed is higher than the
number coming in
with the current staff
right so your current staff is eating
into the backlog because they're closing
more cases than are coming in
that's that's not an indication that you
really need more staff
right more staff will eat through the
backlog even faster true but it but at
least you're you're with the current
in progress but I would disagree with
the premise that with current Staffing
we can eradicate this backlog and even
if we got it only and I hate to Hazard
this but only down to 50 that we're
waiting that's still a chunk of people
that are not getting what it is they're
they're needing we have
um we have an obligation to move through
these cases as expeditiously as possible
not to shortcut anyone but to certainly
move the move through them expeditiously
and so with more hands and the I know we
are focusing on the on the backlog here
and on the cases but that's not the only
part of our statute that we have to
address we are specifically tasked with
Outreach Education and Training and so
there is those things do happen and one
of the prioritized requests was a
training coordinator because what
happens now is with training it's either
myself or the assistant director who
stops what they're doing and does the
specific training now important and
should be done more could be done again
it's back to the number of hands so
although yes the staff is amazing and
they do a great job however there are
other tasks that need to happen and
having more individuals who are moving
through these cases is really going to
give people back time if you are a
complainant and you have to wait you're
waiting so you don't know what's
happening with it maybe you've moved on
with your life maybe you're waiting for
this to finish so that you can move on
with your life for there to be a
determination of whether there was
probable cause that something
discriminatory happened or no probable
cause and if you're a business or
whoever the respondent is you're also
waiting you're waiting for someone to
make this decision so that you can move
on with your business life and so it
would it would be
detrimental of me to not make this
request and looking at what we have and
how we are allocating time and how we
are managing the caseload it does make
sense to ask for more people
thank you representative evil
thank you very much um on page 22 where
we're talking about the remaining needs
for us to really dig in on this I
wondered if you could get us some
numbers
associated with these requests
the numbers such as like
the dollar amount for the individual
this
I
think
this is this yep that sounds like and
then this is something you've got to add
in yeah
okay
if you want to work with Kathy and
she's worked with us before as far as
actual breakdown of the new positions
sure and the costs of saints
all right I have I have this but I'll do
better math we have Kathy or you could
get those to the LBA folks that would be
great
so I I had a few questions myself
so for instance the unassigned uh how do
you prioritize those and how old are
those the unassigned cases
um so thank you for the question
um the unassigned cases go in in order
so if something comes in uh what what
month is this March so if we opened a
charge on March the 7th that case is at
the bottom of the list so we go in order
of of how you walked in the door so we
start from the oldest cases moving
moving to the newest cases
we have people are waiting at least a
year before they are assigned and then a
case could take anywhere from three
months to maybe a year it depends on how
complex it is to have that investigated
or excuse me once it's investigated an
investigation could take anywhere from
three months to a year it depends on how
on how complicated it is in the meantime
what we do offer we have a free media
program so initially out the box people
are offered this program we have around
50 close to 50 volunteer mediators that
work with us so there are retired judges
attorneys certified mediators and as
soon as anyone expresses interest they
are immediately put in touch with our
mediator mediation coordinator that's
also one of the investigators to
schedule a mediation so we offer virtual
so that we're convenient to everyone and
then at any point in time if the two
parties would like to work towards a
settlement and they settle then their
their work with us is done we will then
at that point close the case because in
our understanding that person has been
made whole and and then that case is
closed so they don't have to wait on us
to do an investigation specifically to
to enter into mediation and we make sure
that they know that's possible
so a significant amount of your funding
comes from General funds and I note here
that your request for
I'm 22 is about 830
000 in round numbers
and then up to a 1.2
million in round numbers for General
funds do you get a lot of federal help I
notice there is a line for federal
dollars but it's about 175
000. are you able to get grants or
federal assistance that could help ease
the pain as far as the general funding
part of this thank you for the question
um right now uh with the EEOC which uh
which is our federal partner we work
sort of it's a weird kind of a
reimbursement so we we work the cases
and then we submit them and we get paid
in reimbursement or those cases we do
not have another Federal contract we are
currently beginning the work to connect
with HUD so that would be a different an
additional federal revenue stream that
one would work the same way though it
would be in a reimbursement type
situation so we would take in the charge
work the case and then submit that for
reimbursement so that would be
significant funds whereas the
um EEOC foreclosed case is around 800
um HUD for a closed case could be
anywhere from thirty two hundred to
thirty five hundred and depending on all
of the other things that you might do
there are other opportunities for income
um what we do also is with our trainings
we do charge for the trainings and so we
do bring in a meager amount maybe four
or five thousand depending on the year
could be less it could be more and that
money does go into the general fund and
if at any point
um if there are any fines that are
charged to any of the companies on the
outside on the other side of a hearing
then those dollars would go back to the
general fund
seeing non so I guess you're hopefully
clear on what we need again just work
with Kathy and get that to our LBA folks
and
that would be great
further yeah I'm really sorry when when
you give us the information on the
remaining needs if you could tell us
which of those needs
reach the top of your list
it's like choosing among your children
I'm sure I know because because they're
all the same
[Laughter]
okay thank you no and representative
evil is correct it's a significant one
from going from nine people now to 12 so
as far as what we look at we
try to minimize the number of new
employees if we can
understood just as an example our sister
stayed in Maine which is a similar
population size
um the their office staff is more than I
mean we're all small Maine New Hampshire
Rhode Island certainly but they have the
same number of of investigators and back
in 2011 we were cut down to six and and
the need has continued to grow
so the this is why it's it's hard to say
one or two because just the more hands
the better I'm sure you're familiar with
the house subcommittee that took place
over the summer and we have others that
are certainly willing to to vouch that
we need more hands from the business
Community the legal Community Etc so
um I can sadly prioritize but it's going
to be hard because the four is really
what we need and we'll we're happy with
the three that the Governor has has
allotted us and if we could at least
have that
that would that would make for a a
really robust opportunity for us to dig
in and get this work done and move these
cases along
okay thank you not seeing any further
what's what's that
yeah oh yeah
yeah
so next on our
schedule we have the New Hampshire
Council of developmentally disabilities
I did not prepare PowerPoint
foreign
easy
you've heard that did you yeah okay so
if you could state your name for the
record please it's difficult to spell
spell it for a clerk sure for the record
my name is Isadora Rodriguez legendre
would you like me to spell all of it
do you have a card
um
I do not or maybe it's on your you had a
you couldn't spell yeah I guess you'll
-i-s-a okay
and the last name is r o d
r i
g u
easy hyphen l e g
e n
Dre
yes I currently serve as the executive
director at the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities
we are a 100 percent federally funded
state agency
um our mission we are dedicated to
dignity full rights of citizenship
cultural diversity equal opportunities
and full participation for all New
Hampshire citizens with developmental
disabilities
um the handout I have provided has three
things one is a description of our
organization it has the mission DD
councils were created by federal law
known as the DD act
and because there's a DD Council in
every state and territory we are
federally funded
um
are funding we receive we're what's
known as a minimum allotment state so we
receive about
527 thousand dollars a year currently
um to do our work and so it is
imperative for us to partner with other
organizations that have a similar vision
and values that of full inclusion and
Community participation for people with
developmental disabilities we do
advocacy capacity building and systems
change work so we work with the state
with other disability Justice
organizations
um occasionally we do partner with other
organizations and get some secondary
grant funding through those Partnerships
but it's very minimal
um
the other thing uh that is required by
the DD Act is that our membership be at
least 60 percent individuals with
intellectual or developmental
disabilities and this really guarantees
that our work is driven by the citizens
most impacted by our projects and our
activities we like to fund Innovative
projects and activities that really
um create an on-the-ground impact for
people with developmental disabilities
in New Hampshire and so a large portion
of our funding goes into what we call
our grants and scholarships so line
seven
um
72 class 72 is where the bulk of our
funds typically go aside from salaries
so
um we are required to do A needs
assessment every five years to identify
the most pressing needs of citizens with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities in New Hampshire so we do a
lot of surveys a lot of focus groups we
are connected to a lot of family groups
the area agency system and we really
um
try to incorporate
the findings that this needs assessment
into our five-year state plan
so and there's a visual representation
of our state plan currently in process
we are in year two of our five-year
state plan
and I'm doing well
so
um in our budget
the the only additional need was related
to doit who had requested additional
funds again our funds are all federal
and so it does not impact the general
fund in any way
and I'm happy to answer any questions
one other thing I would like to say is
that when we receive our Federal grant
so last year it was 527 thousand dollars
we have a two-year project period in
which to spend those funds and so that
allows us also to carry forward funds if
needed in cases of government shutdown
continuing resolution or in the unlikely
event that DD councils are unfunded it
would give us a wind down period to be
able to expend those funds so currently
our carry forward is about two hundred
thousand dollars which we have included
in the budget for the next biennium
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman did you lose an
experienced employee sometime recently
because one thing that's unusual about
your budget is the amount being spent in
the new biennium compared to the old the
the salary line is going down so there's
something yes thank you I haven't seen
that before thank you for the question
so we we
did have
um we had three full-time position
currently on the books
um we did lose one employee
last year
and uh again the the health insurance
was a family insurance and it was
someone who was seasoned and so at a
higher uh pay rate than a new staff
person would be we actually took that
opportunity to break the position up
into two part-time positions because we
thought it would meet our needs
um more effectively and so so far so
good we're having trouble recruiting the
second position but
um our hope is that so I think even
though full time went down part-time
are there any further questions
seeing none
I guess we're good
Melissa and Mr Hoffman without objection
all right next we have the Department of
Labor that can be found on page 320 on
the
big budget book I'm sorry representative
Schultz that you don't have a big budget
that looks like
it's the numbers are all different oh my
all right good morning welcome to
division one uh if you please State your
names and if your last name is difficult
or even your first name is difficult to
spell Please spell it for our Clerk
oh thank you uh uh for the record I'm
Ken Merrifield commissioner of the
Department of Labor I'm joined by Deputy
Commissioner Rudy Ogden uh and as you
say Mr chairman our section of the
budget begins on page 320.
um I just have some introductory remarks
and I know that you have questions uh
relative to House Bill 2
um so we'll leave the balance of the
time after that certainly for your
questions uh the Department of Labor
consists of three operating divisions
Administration which is inclusive of
department-wide efforts like human
resources and finance inspection which
is tasked with the enforcement of the
state's employment safety elevator and
pressure vessel statutes and also the
Workers Compensation Division which is
tasked with monitoring the state's
worker compensation system
the inspection division is responsible
for administering and enforcing the
protective legislation law citizens job
Protection Law whistleblowers protection
act the youth employment law the minimum
wage law the New Hampshire Warren act
the boiler and pressure vessel law
elevator and accessibility lift law and
a variety of safety and health laws and
along with these the the associated
administrative rules
um in each of the last three fiscal
years the Inspection Division division
has recovered an average of about a
million dollars in wages for New
Hampshire employees it has completed uh
roughly 500 labor inspections at various
businesses and completed uh ten thousand
or or more boiler and pressure vessel
inspections and over 5 000 elevator
inspections
the division is also proactive training
employers every year on employment law
to assist with businesses uh with with
their legal compliance with labor
statutes and as a consequence of the
public health emergency that began in
the year 2020 the division was forced to
develop and conduct remote electronic
trainings but we are making an effort
this spring to return to in-person
training events all over the state for
Employers in various parts of the state
geographically
uh the Workers Compensation Division was
created in 1947 has the responsibility
for administering the state's work of
compensation law which is RSA 281a this
law was originally enacted in 1911 and
requires employers to maintain insurance
coverage to provide no-fault workers
compensation for employees in the case
of accidental injury death or
occupational disease arising out of the
the course of their employment
among other duties the Workers
Compensation Division collects first
reports of injury from employers or
insurance carriers numbering about forty
thousand a year
it also schedules over 1500 formal
hearings per year and manages a
revolving trust fund Collections and
payments of as high as 20 million
dollars a year which as you can see is
about twice the size of our operating
budget
while the Department's total
Appropriations however are funded 100
percent by agency income that revenue is
derived through two distinct sources the
administration fund and the restricted
fund
the administration fund is described in
RSA 281 a colon 59 and it comes from a
pro rata assessment of the Department's
annual budget for workers compensation
activities and that is levied on
insurance carriers and self-insured
entities in New Hampshire and that that
part of our agency income represents
about 88 percent of our biennial Revenue
requests that's before you the
restricted fund that is described in RSA
273 colon 1B comes from the sum of all
other
fees licenses certificates and civil
penalties of the department
the ballot and then the balance of the
restricted fund at the end of each
fiscal year is transferred to the
general fund so once once all of our
activities are paid for the balance goes
back to the general fund
um the department has happily reported
record revenues in general fund
transfers in each of the last two years
exceeding two million dollars for the
first time in fiscal 21 and 3 million
dollars in fiscal 22.
uh in our biennial agency request
self-funded agencies were not required
to meet the governor's efficiency
expenditure targets but the labor
department has done so nonetheless
um in our 2024 efficiency request
governor's office provided an overall
efficiency Target of just over 11
million dollars in year one
representing a three percent increase
from 23 adjusted authorized and the uh
adjusted year two target was 11.25
Million with allowances for position
cost increases
again we met both of those targets with
our efficiency budget request and apart
from certain priority needs that were
requested by other agencies as a
transfer from us all of our requests
were were accepted by the governor
we have requested no new positions for
State fiscal year 24-25 having abolished
eight full-time positions in the last
biennium but the governor's expenditure
targets did allow us to fully fund all
remaining 86 full-time permanent
positions in our budget
other operational changes that we've
requested in our agency budget include
the addition of a new class 103 for
contracts and we envision using the
using this for certain operational needs
we've traditionally historically the
labor department has not had contract
lines in the budget and we have run into
certain needs there so we've we've asked
for a new uh budget line for contracts
we're also requesting a new board
expenses class 65 as a companion to
language in House Bill 2 that will allow
us to pay per diem members of an
important administratively attached
board that is has presented some
recruitment difficulties for us
um so we've asked for a new uh pay line
there for that board and we've also
increased the amount of money available
for employee training due to concerns
that we've had in recent years over
staff turnover uh and and in addition an
ongoing technology launch new technology
launch in the department and speaking of
that uh priority funding included by the
governor in both years of the biennium
includes about 135 thousand dollars per
year for doit services
largely in support of the Department's
first new technology launch uh in some
20 years the intent there the intent
there is to replace an aging 1980s IBM
as400 system which I believe is going to
be the last one in operation in state
government if it isn't already
so we're replacing that we did launch a
new document management system a little
more than a year ago and we are
gradually moving functions off of the
IBM and onto this new system
and so that concludes my remarks we're
happy to answer any questions here
represent McGuire and thank you Mr
chairman yeah I don't know who's more
behind on technology you were the liquor
department but I'm going to say it's us
yeah yeah they they're replacing a 40
year old system as well so there you go
all right
um can you tell me uh in the Inspection
Division why is the number of boiler
inspections vary so much from year to
year well I think if you're looking at
the statistics that we've provided in
and
I'm sorry page five of your handout
right right from the handout uh
State fiscal year 2020 still coping with
uh effects of the pandemic uh many of
many employers many uh device owners did
not want us in their buildings I see so
2020 got pushed into 21 so 21 was big
and now we're back to normal
uh yes relatively normal yes gotcha okay
um and one more question
I remember from my last stint as a State
Rep that our workman's comp rates were
considerably higher than Massachusetts
is that true to choose it's being a
different model
um the the structure of the workers
compensation system in Massachusetts is
very different in fact the the national
Clearinghouse of statistics for workers
compensation does not include
Massachusetts in their statistics at all
because of the the different way that
they fund their system so how do we rank
sort of nationally or I don't know how
we rank but well insurance is probably
the better source of information on this
but rates have been declining over
recent years but if you could use the
mic I'm sorry the rates have been
declining but I would say relative to
the costs under workers compensation we
Trend High
um there was as you might remember from
your time discussion of a fee schedule
things of that nature we do not have a
fee schedule accordingly if you look at
again to the commissioner's Point
Massachusetts is not included in these
statistics but if you look at us even
regionally the provider payment rates
are are high in New Hampshire for
workers compensation yeah we have
expensive hospitals and Etc
thank you
and you might remember uh legislation
that was passed oh boy I forget what
year this was it was prior to my arrival
of labor but
um there was legislation passed uh
creating uh section 24 of the workers
compensation statute that um shifted the
burden of proof to the providers about
the reasonableness of cost and that was
that was uh compromised to to avoid
going to a full fee schedule versus the
the prior system with with those burdens
of proof were were reversed
representative Schultz and on a summer
similar note where do we rank in
unemployment compensation say on the
lower end average compared to all the
other states I I wish I could tell you
but that's not under our purview
employment security has purview for
unemployment okay so that's not under
you yeah it doesn't fall in our business
pretty sure it's the lowest in the
country for whatever it's worth
no apology necessary or new to the
not understood that the common comments
that many states have combined those
functions in the labor department but
here it's more fragmented
several agencies so you have a number of
issues in House Bill 2 which yes we
spoke to yesterday I Mr Hoffman and
Melissa
yes
um on pages 39 to 42 there's sections
111 through 1 8. teen have to do with
we have 111 this civil penalties
I can describe what we're what we're
trying to accomplish there uh
you might remember from my remarks I
talked about the two primary sources of
revenue at the labor department being
the restricted fund of the
administration Fund in 2011 the
legislature created the restricted fund
to
um
to fund all activities of the department
that were not associated with workers
compensation and so every civil penalty
every uh certificate license fee
everything else we collect besides the
administration fund was directed into
the restricted fund and the statute
literally says all
unfortunately not every passage in the
statutes was corrected at that time and
so this turned up these turned up well
one or two of these turned up in an LBA
audit this past year the Deputy
Commissioner also did a more thorough
search of the statutes looking for any
misdirected funds that should be
directed to the restricted fund as
intended by the legislature in 2011. so
it is literally clean up of yeah
you know
do you have an idea what the general
fund would lose if we didn't change this
language
not a thing because the balance is being
sent to the general fund anyway the the
applicable uh penalties that we're
describing here are far less than what
we turn over to the general fund
Sony concerns about 111 and we have I
guess 112 which is workers compensation
liability
and then going down 113
114 units
I guess it's still under the labor isn't
and and if I might just comment uh on
Section 114 what we've done there is to
it we we have on the workers
compensation side of the house we have
in a pellet board who we pay in exactly
the same way and so we've lifted the
Deputy Commissioner Has Lifted the
language uh from that statute to place
it under the penalty appeal board
because we're having difficulty well in
fact as long ago as 1995 the lva cited
the department for not turning out
decisions from the penalty appeals board
in a timely fashion and we have had
difficulty recruiting for this as a as a
volunteer position so we think it's
important for people to be able to
appeal decisions of the commissioner
relative to penalties and this board uh
we think we we need to inspire people to
participate in this board
so
yes representative uh what you said you
were conforming this to which board the
compensation appeals board okay
uh which is a 33-member pool uh they sit
in uh appeals of decisions of our
hearings Bureau they sit in three-member
tribunals to determine uh uh
compensibility and other issues
associated with worker compensation
cases
when there's been an appeal and they are
any problem with 114
represent Maguire thank you
um so because we're going to give them
give this per diem uh what do you think
the expense of the board how much will
it yeah
um we estimated that and included it in
uh 20 000 per year okay is what we're
estimating uh far less busy than the
compensation appeals board which you'll
see is hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year so I'm guessing that workman's
comp rates are set such that they
generate what your budget needs is it is
that right or is it
or is it the other way around you you
manage your budget
to get what the rates give you
uh well our our budget as approved by
the general court is an assessment for
for just for workers compensation
activities right so then we bill that to
the insurance carriers on a pro-rata
basis based on the claims that they have
paid in the prior year
um relative to rates it has much more to
do with their experience you know what
claims have they paid and so forth set
by the insurance department right right
I mean correct their rates are primarily
driven on their experience and whether
they've had what their loss experience
has been in preceding years oh okay so
so we set your budget here
that's the amount you have to ask them
for is that you build them for that
correct they they figure it out right
absolutely for for what it's worth it's
negligible compared to the amount of
claims paid sure
do you mind repeating which
um board it is that you are eager to
have volunteers for because I that we
had have a problem yeah with uh yes the
penalty appeals board
they they hear appeals of decision
Decisions by my office relative to civil
penalties
um in a variety of circumstances but
they have the opportunity to appeal that
um and what we have been left to is to
settling cases
um with folks rather rather than going
so next we have 115 a workers
compensation payment for a second
injuries from a special fund
uh
again this looks a little
deep on the first read have you run any
of these uh by the labor committee by
chance to get there
position on it sometimes we refer it if
there's a policy issue that catches our
attention we ask the policy committee to
weigh in I can say that we've had
discussions with the chairman of Labor
uh and also the Attorney General's
office and the governor's office for
years about this I could I could offer
that the the second injury funds
throughout the country 2022 states have
ended their second injury funds
um
yeah but that's been the extent of our
discussions with house labors actually
with the chairman
representative Schultz here on labor
right normally does anything look
familiar to you here or I'm still new to
the labor committee so I mean it's
always nice to talk to the ranking
member of the minority party too I would
say but um
I mean I
I can't speak for the labor Committee
well so we'll assign you if you could
check with your colleagues on the labor
committee about section 115 please it
might be happy to get back to us very
shortly I feel well tasked thank you I
sit behind the chair and vice chair I
could lean on over and ask on Thursday
we try to stick with money but when we
see policy we try to reach out to the
representative evil yeah so the upshot
though of 115 is you're getting rid of
the second injury we would be sunsetting
new claims new claims and if I could
give you uh
an example from my research the the
state of Connecticut did almost
precisely the same thing in 1995 their
fund is still operating today
so it's a very gradual departure from
in the case so represents Schultz you
have an assignment there how about 116
for family medical leave Insurance sure
um
the the Family and Medical Leave
Provisions in
the prior House Bill too
addressed one part of our statute
so it's a prohibited activity for an
employer who signs on to the program to
retaliate or discriminate against an
employee who uses the program
what wasn't clear to us however was
how how the labor department was
supposed to properly react to complaints
about that so we're just we're asking
for rule making Authority so that we can
Define that more clearly
we know that it's a prohibited act but
how does the the labor department
respond do we uh do we offer a hearing
do we accept a hearing do we investigate
the employer
um you know we just wanted to clarify
that
can quit questions from anybody on 116
representative McGuire thank you is the
amount you that the employer might be
fined or something is that known or
probably not we have a statute that
grants us uh twenty five hundred dollars
maximum per violation that would
probably be applied in this case
um that would be my expectation really
we wouldn't try to Define if
fine
so are we okay with 116.
okay
now we have the boiler and pressure
vessels
uh
what we're what we're attempting to
accomplish there is the correction of a
scrivener's error that we believe
happened in 1988
just catching up to it yeah not as old
as you know we tutor though
yeah we tend to find these things on
occasion
um we believe that the statute the
statute changed in 1988 because a small
section was added and we believe that
the the published version of the law
changed the word from and to or vice
versa and uh we don't believe that that
was the result of any legislative action
it was simply an error so that's all
we're trying to uh accomplish here all
right so I guess we'll say Mr Hoffman on
117.
and here we go workman's comp uh appeals
board
yes
um uh it's been
it's been noted in in our statistics uh
over quite some time uh more than a
decade that the volume associated with
appeals at the workers compensation
appeals board has been declining
the 33-member pool was established quite
a long time ago decades ago when there
was a huge backlog from the superior
court that needed to be addressed we we
don't believe that we need 33 seeds on
this board in order to accomplish the
this
evening
I don't think so I think that's it
well thank you very much okay thank you
okay
foreign
ready yeah okay
well well we can get started
um thank you commissioner will you
all right so um commissioner I apologize
would you remind me your name
happy to do that Helen Hanks
thanks thank you
um so Corrections is our largest
the corrections appreciate the
opportunity to present the budget uh to
my right is John Hanson our director of
administration
in the packet we point out our mission
statement on page one and the areas we
are uh statutory obligated to facilitate
which include running the correctional
facilities probation parole victim
services and acting and advisory
capacity with other law enforcement
agencies
on page two we give a high level
overview of the FY 2425 Governor's
recommended budget
I don't think it's a surprise to this
committee that a large portion of our
budget is salaries and benefits in FY 24
that represents 73.3 and an fy25 73.7
percent of the budget
the other area of the budget that is a
larger component obviously in the
delivery of Health Care Services to
incarcerated residents they have a they
are the only population who has a
constitutional obligation to provide
appropriate Access to Health Care from
any citizen in the United States of
America so our medical budget represents
12.8 percent in FY 24 and 12.6 percent
fy25
the other operational costs will go
through those those that are greater
than a million and less than a million
but you'll see in the table Below on
page two we highlight the actual the
adjusted authorized for FY 23 and the
governor's recommended in the two
following years
if you would the commissioner I I'm
looking at a discrepancy here between
your 149 3 and what I see on page 534 of
um 155 6. so is there some attached
thing or something like that maybe the
Adult Parole Board numbers
the pro board is about 6 million total
six no no not people million
[Laughter]
dollars
yeah oh the numbers on the slide I know
we raised his salary a few dollars but
numbers on the slide on page to just
represent general fund dollars so the
numbers within the budget will include
um Grant dollars and some other dollars
including the adult parole board thank
uh on page two you'll take notice that
the areas we see increasing obviously
your salary and benefits prescription
drugs and medical payments to providers
in the up and coming years
and then obviously utilities I think as
individuals paying our own electric
bills as you could imagine we talked the
last time the utility cost across the
on page three we dive into the salary
and benefits specifically for 973
full-time funded positions we've
allocated 5.49 million in the overtime
line and would ask for continued use of
a footnote that we've used that looks at
all of the lines associated with
personnel and allow us to through the
fiscal committee and governor and
Council transfer funds to fill in over
time that is incurred through vacancies
well that has worked really well and I
again I think it's an appropriate way to
say to the Department of Corrections
continue to fill those vacancies and
give hope to the staff that are working
every day that will be able to continue
and move that needle forward in a
uh on page four we drill down into the
medical and Pharmacy budget not included
on here I do want to let the committee
know that the agency was able to move
forward with some 340b pricing on
Pharmaceuticals which is a a significant
savings we partnered with health and
human services and started to move that
needle forward to look at things such as
hepatitis C Pharmaceuticals which are
higher cost and as we become more expert
in that area we'll roll in other
Pharmaceuticals because there are heavy
reporting requirements and we want to
make sure we serve the state right in
that regard as well as save money
we do ask on page four to highlight and
to continue to have that footnote health
care costs are definitely unpredictable
disease states are unpredictable and
being able to come back for unknown
circumstances or Market circumstances to
fiscal and GNC to ask for additional
on page five highlight areas in the 9.6
percent range of the general fund budget
our food services it might surprise you
that every day we serve 5 700 meals
across the agency at an average cost per
meal of 375 per day so although those
costs are going up I think we've
controlled them given the nature of the
economy in a way that's reasonable
the consumables area current expense
otherwise class 20 commonly referred to
those numbers go up slightly the cost of
things do cost more
the other area that um we we put some
attention to is our equipment or class
30 costs we continue to need to upgrade
our Fleet we spent the last several
years upgrading our Field Services Fleet
our most community-based mobile Fleet
and now we need to shift course and look
at our transportation vehicles our other
maintenance and logistic vehicle
vehicles that go back as early as I
think our oldest one is from the 80s
maybe late 80s yeah so we need to put
some attention to those the other area
we don't commonly talk about but it is
time to again invest in equipment are in
our infirmary Suites our hospital beds
the resources our Health Care staff use
on a regular basis to care for people
who are informed and we need to address
those as well as continuing to look for
efficiencies in the delivery of our
Pharmaceuticals and reduce any type of
medication error opportunity through
on page six we dive into utility costs
uh we did send some information after
the last agency briefing but we
highlight an example of the definite
significant changes in our utilities
costs and new to the agency but
similarly for administrative Services we
ask for the inclusion of a opportunity
to come back if utility costs exceed
what's forecasted and put in our budget
from admin Services I think that's
reasonable given what we've seen the
last year an unexpected
forecasting in the future
so the hope would be to save money but
in the event that we don't have enough
money that you will have the
understanding we'll go through the
fiscal and GDC process to ask for
so I've noticed under utilities you've
been
been able to reduce the usage over time
it looks like pretty well is that mainly
related to fewer inmates I think you
could make that a logical link that the
reduction in incarcerated population has
reduced some of those costs great thank
you yeah and some increases in LED
lighting and small Nuance changes we've
tried to implement thank you for that
question
under office of Information Technology
expenses you'll see those costs for FY
24 and 25 part of heavy initiatives
we're trying to use and look at are the
uses of technology to help the
efficiency of our staffing situation but
also to create Bridges to education and
other rehabilitative programs and not
try to do it all ourselves in that for
example we are part of the authorization
reauthorization of the Pell Grant and
we're working with a New England
Commission on higher education and
prisons as well as a group called
evolving prisons and connected
communities and some of these
initiatives both allow us to create
technological resources for our staff
but also technological paths for staff
to provide education and other treatment
opportunities Wellness is an issue not
just for people incarcerated but for the
staff they're working every day and
we're also trying to create new and
Progressive Pathways forward to give
them opportunities on their break to
check in if they need a Telehealth visit
or a wellness visit for their own
benefit and we want to be a better
partner in their own work-life balance
so some of these initiatives move that
forward an important tool and
Corrections is also the radio
telecommunications system that is a
critical tool a safety tool and so what
this item also works to both fix the
hardware situation software situations
associated with an analog system and
moving to a digital system
in addition to that we want to get off
paper I see a lot of paper in this room
but if you can imagine we keep a still
more paper than we need on residents
files and we want to move that to a
digital system and get to a more
efficient system and Corrections
um trying to highlight we do use General
applications uh vendor management system
an electronic health record an
electronic pharmaceutical system we are
looking at other systems again to create
progress both from an incident reporting
as well as use of fiscal Force reporting
system to make sure we are as
transparent as possible when one of
those events happens and we can expedite
that type of review mitigating the time
one of our staff might be out under
investigation and getting them back
return to the environment because we can
swiftly and show exactly what happened
we further have deployed when I get
ahead of myself I was about to I'll wait
till I get to the next page
um on the following page these are other
notable changes in the budget book our
rents and leases for our district
offices have gone up but in addition to
that we're making a we're asking to make
a change in this budget to lease tasers
energy conducted weapons as they're
referred to I learned early on taking
the Helm of this agency that we bought
them and that's also not a way to stay
on top of technology in its expensive
way in a liable way to maintain
technology but they have a leasing
program where you lease them the shelf
life is not something you're tracking
but they also provide training and other
resources when you you move that way so
this looks to lease about 106 tasers
across the whole organization we changed
this already in our Field Services
Department it's been very effective now
we want to do this in our correctional
facilities
a question from representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman thank you again
thank you for being here so what would
be the cost to buy 106 tasers as opposed
approximately three thousand dollars
taser
yes representative
Schultz sorry
um
that's a lot of money I have no idea
that they were that expensive yes for
whatever it's worth I bought one from
this is a different kind of thankfully I
haven't used it and I've never brought
it to the legislature maybe if you would
admit that either
um
so I'm just surprised though uh from
that research that I did on my own that
teaser technology would change that much
over
the short term
um
I guess that's not a question but it
just seems like a lot per taser for if
you have working tasers what is I guess
I guess the question would be then
what's the biggest difference then
between an old taser that you already
own and one of these new tasers of
course setting aside the training
benefit you get from that arrangement
representative Schultz that's a great
question and uh the tasers themselves
actually have an expiration date and I
did not know that until I worked in
Corrections the taser you have at home
versus the taser we use in a law
enforcement environment has an
expiration date it has
um technology within the software that
actually gets uh outdated over time
because it actually tracks when those uh
barbs and its usage as well as it has a
video apparatus on the device to
videotape that event as well so there's
all of these systems of redundancy
within the system another area just as
an example that I didn't realize came
with a expiration date it's also a stab
resistant vest I would have thought in
layman's terms prior to my law
enforcement experience that that best is
always good it expires the other
important factor in handing a
corrections officer an expired taser and
then being in a use of fiscal Force
event is the liability of not having
current and effective technology that's
backed in litigation
yeah yeah
what about the consumables part of the
taser does that include it in the lease
or you have to buy that that's all of it
is all inclusives uh in the lease that's
a great question too yeah
um the other area of the department
obviously Staffing is critical in order
to attract and recruit staff and retain
staff employee development is an area
this agency took the opportunity this
budget to really put dollars behind and
it might not look like a lot at the end
of the day averaging about 205 dollars
per person but we haven't invested a lot
in employee training and that
information technology is also to create
Pathways to training because we need to
be realistic about how much in-person
training we can offer and how much that
offer we also need to build the skill
sets of those working Behind the Walls
and risk assessing Crisis Intervention
training not just responding to a mental
health event but being a peer supporter
within a correctional environment
motivational interviewing skills
fundamental law enforcement skills
including firearms and advanced firearms
training and then buying the training
materials as even down to the
ammunitions we require all come out of
this funding line and we really wanted
to put a mark on employee development
employee training across the Diversified
areas because we have law enforcement
employees we have clinical employees we
have case management employees probation
and parole officer employees we have
teachers we have a community of
Professional Services that we need to be
investing in and and that's what these
numbers represent
uh in addition to other notable changes
in the for the agency is ongoing
expenses for the current procurement of
body and vehicle cameras and in addition
to an employee Wellness application and
victim information and notification
every day we referred to as Vine
software that vine software is for
victims and survivors of crime in a
self-service technology way to say how
and when they want to be notified about
the person who's incarcerated through
email
telephonic and or other methods of
communication and the when is important
someone doesn't necessarily want to know
all the time what's going on but when
somebody's accessing the community and
everywhere in between so these expenses
are outlined under contract for program
services and show a notable change from
on page eight I highlight our house
House Bill 2 requests under the
governor's recommended again the
transfer Authority that allows us to
help
fill in the overtime expenses due to
vacancies and then the
the bottom of page eight starts a series
of currently classified positions
seeking to make them unclassified
positions so if you will these are
classified Deputy directors both Deputy
Warden deputy director of rehabilitative
services and a deputy director of Health
Services we run 24 7 facilities it only
makes sense to put these individuals in
an unclassified or as a private sector
salaried type position for the
accessibility we learned a lot about
this through covid-19 and make this ask
I do want to point out that the deputy
Warden classified position is a group
two law enforcement position and this
ask is to keep them unclassified but a
group two unclassified because they work
on a daily basis Behind the Walls of the
prison and contact with prisoners
what I see in the budget is that the
number of unclassified positions is the
same
is is at 19 unchanging but these are
adding some is yeah so this goes through
that great question this goes through
the hb2 process and the foot footnote
includes that if it is afforded that
opportunity those three classify that
exist in that number now would switch in
the budget to three unclassified so
we're not gaining we're switching as
so that discussion continues through
page nine and on the top of page 10
talking about those goals uh in the
middle of page 10 there are there are
three position numbers the way uh the
agency needs to navigate
um putting people properly in a group
two Correctional line Personnel position
is to bring it to the legislature
because we had a sunset Clause occur and
we've added licensed nursing assistance
to the Direct Care model in our prisons
who work every single day one-on-one
providing health care and security with
people incarcerated and what often looks
like an obscure title the administrative
obscure psychiatric unit is in a secure
unit every day interacting with
incarcerated individuals who are
mentally ill so these three meet the
statutary statutory definition I'm
asking to see those transitions so they
get equal benefit as people working
is there going to be a one-time charge
to the
um or in addition to the unfunded
liability when we switch somebody from
group one to group two we did the
analysis the last go around and happy to
dive into that in this instance hold on
I'll see if Lisa knows that right off
with me is Lisa Stone she's our deputy
director of administrative Services you
unfunded liability between the switch of
group one to group two right do we have
to put in when we when we change
somebody from group one to group two
group two normally would have a lot more
um saved for them at a certain point in
their career right so so do we need to
oh I see they're only group two going
forward they're not group two for their
total career I see thank you very much
you know I knew the answer to that but I
didn't understand your question I'm glad
we had that dialogue yes it's a split
benefit I myself when I started in 2003
was a group two employee and I switched
to a group one employee in 2009 uh five
so I'm a split benefit moving forward
you're welcome these three positions are
um on the bottom of page 10 uh which
would be the what I was trying to do was
streamline law
uh in the existing section this does not
do away with these positions because the
positions stricken is a position
referenced above in that section of
Statute I was merely trying to clean up
a sentence because it lists the
commissioner assistant commissioner the
Professional Standards director the
director of personnel of an information
the director of rehabilitative services
and the division directors we have other
division directors so this is just a
cleanup and the other two directors
specifically reference were supposed to
be stricken so it was a clean sentence
the commissioner assistant commissioner
and division directors so on and so
forth
on page 11 we get into the depth of what
I know I have spoken to a lot of
individuals about but the governor's
included an hb2
establishment of a non-lapsing fund to
begin the purpose of design and
construction of a New Hampshire state
prison for men
we've done a lot of work the last few
years looking at our ass to the capital
budget overview committee and saying how
do we as a state and how do we as a
department move the needle forward given
the cost and price tag of a new New
Hampshire state prison for men
the oldest infrastructure being from
1878. and in doing so and talking to the
treasury and understanding what is
allocated each year there wasn't a path
forward we understood what the bonding
rate was but how do we Bond over 300
million or 500 million dollars
and the discussions I've had resulted in
this outcome which I think is a great
place to begin it provides a path
forward it says we're we understand and
I would say we understand as a
department that investing in a new
prison might not be everybody's top
priority are there other areas to invest
in but I can tell you today that that
infrastructure is failing that
environment is part of our retention
problem it is not the place in which we
are rehabilitating people in a long-term
situation we have more tarps and hoses
going to buckets than we should at that
particular location and this starts
moving that forward in an assertive way
and I I would ask that members of this
committee and the full legislature
support the intent what the governor is
trying to accomplish in addition to if
you've not been to the New Hampshire
state prison for men we offer that
opportunity to you we will show you that
prison and then we will show you the New
Hampshire correctional facility for
women and you will see the stark
contrast between something that started
its infrastructure in 1878 and I'm not
talking about an old beautiful Farmhouse
talking about a correctional institution
and a facility built and moved into in
2018. and you will see the difference
between a rehabilitative environment
designed with efficiency and an
environment built over time that is no
longer efficient for Staffing and is
slowly no longer appropriate for housing
individuals in an incarcerated setting
so that this is what is outlined on page
11. I'm certainly happy to answer any
questions
yes representative evil
since they're most closely involved with
this have you in your discussions with
the public works and highways committee
have you told them what's happening in
the operating budget and
when you're talking about your needs and
I meet with them on Friday and I was
very happy to see members of that
committee join a tour from last week so
we'll continue that conversation in
depth on Friday and I know that I have
discussed it in the past talking about
the investment and appropriate
investment made in the infrastructure as
we move forward but oftentimes referred
to it as a drop of a mortgage payment
that would be better spent
so this is almost like developing a
capital reserve Fund in a way to build a
new prison that's a great way to
describe it okay thank you you're
welcome so you talked about
it you talked about efficiency
um it's my understanding that the Men's
prison in Berlin is the most efficient
of the three in terms of
um inmates per officer is that right I
think that's a fair representation and
again another facility designed
understanding creating Staffing because
that was built in 2000.
because and I've heard a criticism of
the women's prison in that it wasn't
designed as efficiently as Berlin is
that right or am I wrong I wouldn't say
that that's uh correct I would say they
both designed efficiently
okay so they do they have similar number
of officers per inmates there were fewer
officers at the women's facility than
there is at the North Country Facility
by sheer volume we only have
approximately just over 100 people
incarcerated but there's only this
actually one person to 56 people at the
women's facility and at the North
Country facility in 2009 when we went
through a major budget reduction they
went from the same model to what's
called a roving model and so a group of
officers move unit to unit to unit to do
the count one would argue that that
roving model creates more risk because
there's no direct Supervision in the
unit that facility was designed to be a
direct supervision model so there are
criticisms of both directions but I
would say they're both efficiently
staffed at this point we've vetted the
roving model since 2010 it's worked and
in some cases at the North Country
facility we've gone back to the direct
supervision model because we have to
modified therapeutic communities for
substance use disorder and we have an
officer on first shift on those units
obviously to mitigate any Contraband
issues around substance use you said one
officer for 56 that's the women's prison
is designed with two C3 units 56 total
capacity in each unit and it's one
officer to 56.
so the whole prison has two officers
nope
three units there is one unit called the
special management unit like houses are
maximum security closed custody step
down or step up from General our
reception and diagnostic that's a
two-person unit and then we have our C2
minimum security on that campus that's a
representative Campbell thank you Mr Jay
and I imagine that's three shifts you
got to multiply it by three you're gonna
multiply it by three and then some
because you need a relief Factor people
do deserve a day off so it's usually
about a 4.25 Factor multiplication
thank you you're welcome right because
there's weekends right yeah yeah okay
all right yes representative evil sorry
I just have a couple more saying I was
involved in the women's prison I have a
cup so do you have an idea of where you
want to put the new Men's prison
I think before you sit on the property
there yeah we um we the state own the
parcel behind the women's prison and
we're having those conversation with
Public Works about that acreage and
we've had preliminary conversations that
it would fit there in acreage we have to
do the same borings we did at the
women's prison and check the ledge
Factor but I think there is a definite
opportunity to put it behind it
and so um
what would you anticipate the design
month so both of these uh Appropriations
say designing and constructing the new
prison what would you anticipate the
design portion of it would cost and if
this money was deposited would you
initiate that immediately
but representative John Hanson I can I
can help uh answer that question so
there is actually a percentage Factor
that's used on the cost per square foot
of buildings of that size so if you ask
an architectural engineering firm what
it would cost to design something of
that size they're going to use let's say
it's a 300 million dollar facility it's
going to be about 25 million just in
designing and on top of that as you know
25 million yeah oh sorry usually too
loud and well no we've got this oh so um
yeah probably probably in the vicinity
of 25 million per 300 million dollar
facility that's just a rough estimate
based on talking with architectural
firms as I have building up to this but
keep in mind a lot of the work that
we'll need to do on that end is to
develop those programs which are
required by law the Llama decree and the
other things that um that you're
familiar with so that there would be a
lot of extra work
done to make sure we designed something
that fits the state law fits our needs
so that that's some rough figures and if
the price goes up there would obviously
be a higher factor for the design of
that you know we're looking at as a
commissioner mentioned it the property
up back
that that whole concept that we use for
the women's prison could be replicated
up there we believe we're not sure until
we do as the commissioner pointed out
borrowings and test bits and we've
already delineated the wetlands we did
that as part of the other project so
we're pretty comfortable with the 383
Acres that we have up there will be out
of sight out of mind abutting the
backside of the Concord property that's
the Calvary Cemetery a budding the other
side of the property which would be
petticook Lake uh it's a new name for it
now the Concord Reservoir
um and that's pretty much it up on that
Hill
some of that
month that you have coming through the
capital budget is being used to look at
the property is that what you just said
we would have to take a look at the
property in that way we're working with
Das and public works on the Deeds right
now to make sure that we're satisfied
we're it's more of a belt and suspenders
approach where we've already shacked but
we want to double check to make sure
there's not a special easement for the
other source or utility lines that go
through from Unitil but we're pretty
well satisfied with the size and if we
do the same thing we did and crush the
rocks that we did last time and not
you have experience yeah a little
experience there we brought very little
material into the site and we hope to do
that again so we don't interfere with
the city of Concord is our good
neighbors to the north they have our
general facilities building there so
that that's one of our plans
and I just
so could you talk to us about the secure
psychiatric unit and what's happening
with that
world
what's that world I would not hasten to
talk about what Health and Human
Services is doing but I yes but I do
have a timeline that they put out in a
Public Presentation we'd happy to make
sure it is sent to this committee we are
obviously monitoring that timeline
because some portion of our patient
population will move over there once
it's built but we'll send that out it's
been a topic of discussion as we've
moved through
yeah okay thank you representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chairman when we're
talking about the new construction for a
new building in the design obviously
we're still sort of early in that
process but how do you determine what
the capacity needs to be for the new
prison is it what we have now times a
factor for what we might need 30 years
from now or what what goes into that
process that's a great question we had
to do the same forecasting on the
women's population looking at historical
population and I want to be clear it's
not just the numbers incarcerated it's
the actual classification levels in the
history of that as well because you have
to build those security classification
levels based on that at the time we did
the design for the women's prison I'm
going to give you this example the
trending and tracking was that the
population was going to increase and
that's what the data told us so the
facility was built with a maximum
capacity of 224 with the understanding
from the legislature that we created a
space in case we needed to boost that
number higher than 300. we've moved in
and filled the capacity and the state's
trend of incarceration actually went
down
um so some of the unanswered part of
your question is it will depend on what
the state passes for sentencing laws
what the state does to intercept
incarceration and create diversion paths
and some of what we saw was the
Statewide implementation post that
design of drug courts that reduce that
for women so to answer your question we
will look at the trended history of the
incarcerated men's population by
classification type
and I will tell you this agency's been
very proactive in reducing the use of C5
or restrictive housing so
we would look at our history and see
that it was up by the last two years we
would see it go down so we'd factor that
all in we'd look and forecast at what
the fine legislature was passing for
laws and work with the design company on
what that data is telling us
you're welcome representative Schultz
did you have a question I didn't think
you noticed my hand thank you
um two things first the not really
selfish but for my constituents as a
Concord rep I would love to see the land
at some point since you offered tours
I'm actually not on the finance
committee but I would love to see if
other Concord reps if you're open to it
how you know as this moves further down
the line we'd love to to see that and
connected to that is a real question
um
is there because I have toured at least
a section of the jail the psychiatric
secure unit before and
um I actually was impressed with the
overall you know obviously I like most
people support it moving
to a different facility for health
reasons and for family reasons but
that's neither here nor there I thought
the facilities looked good but I did not
get a full tour so is there a thought
that any aspect of the existing
facilities could be still in use
uh representative Schultz thank you for
your comments the I was curious
psychiatric and it would look better
because in 2010 it had a capital
investment made into it and we
definitely were happy to show you the
reception and diagnostic area built
again the foundation of 1870. I'm sorry
I
and maybe this is what you're getting
ready to say I apologize that's all
right I I really meant for as you look
to possibly building a new facility is
is there a belief or a possibility even
that um the current space can be looked
at and assessed to be either renovated
or in some fashion used
I think it's a fair question I will tell
you that if we attempt to use any
portion of the existing campus and a new
campus that's not Staffing efficient but
designing a facility that is not campus
style will be Staffing efficient so
right now at the Men's prison you walk
in you have to go over to this building
to that building to this building
because it was built over time
Corrections facilities are not built in
a campus style because it's not Staffing
efficient I think everyone has asked
that reasonable question which is what
would you do with that infrastructure
and some of the carefulness in my
responses we clearly don't want
necessarily a public function occurring
on a correctional campus but also
mindful that even that building recently
had its roof blown off so as much as
we've had portions of it done at earlier
years the infrastructure we keep it
clean we keep it painted but I'm not
sure it would end up with a staffing
efficiency but we'll be mindful of what
we can do with State research sources
you're welcome and yes your previous one
was a question happy to give you a tour
is there extra land in Berlin
so the land in Berlin we wouldn't
attempt to think to build a new prison
up there because of the recruitment
issues for the diverse Diversified
professionals we need we are also
recruiting um for positions up there but
the largest mass with the women's prison
down here the warehouse our transitional
housing units again it creates an
organizational efficiency to continue to
look at Concord
all right
on page 12 you'll see an appropriation
again funding the computer information
the literal physical computers we use an
appropriation for that replacement
and then for the footnote that talks
about Corrections Officers salaries I
want to be clear that's to make sure
that part-time Corrections Officers and
the corrections officer majors are paid
commensurable to the negotiated
contracts there has been some debate
about that and we want to make sure we
solidify that if we recruit a part-time
corrections officer they receive equal
pay for equal work the same for our
corrections officer majors
on the bottom of hb2 is an ask from the
Department and ask for the house finance
to consider an inclusion in hb2 I sent
this language post the agency
presentation if you'll recall on that
presentation and and I know that others
who aren't able to be present I'm sure
I've seen that on page 13 that the
department has remitted reallocation
packets to the division of personnel we
don't know what the analysis will result
in as far as salary adjustments this
language allows for the state to respond
to those salary adjustments whatever
that number may be again I'll just
remind that corrections officer trainees
and Corrections Officers are the lowest
paid state law enforcement because the
agency didn't keep up with adjusting
their job descriptions and we are trying
to rectify that situation and ask for
this language to be included I will also
reaffirm that the state troopers had a
similar footnote in the hb4 that came
out in FY 19 and 20 so there is some
history of trying to rectify these
no I I don't know but I do I do know
that the state is in negotiations and
was also in negotiations during that
time so I would defer to the governor's
office to help assist in that question
and I'd be curious
I thought I heard you say you came up
with this later
well this is definitely a movement in
progress
um and carefulness we did just submit
all of those packets uh post the
governor finalizing his budget
yeah
a lot of moving parts so I never a speak
for the governor's office and be here I
am today
representative Sweeney
Mr chairman so on on page 13. so in an
Ideal World I think minimizing overtime
as much as possible by
increasing either the salaries or
whatever we need to increase Recruitment
and Retention the
I guess proposed in another divisions
talking about the proposed 10 percent
across the board hike is that enough for
Corrections Officers in order to meet
the retaining and recruitment goals or
or where what are we looking at what
what would we need to do to be able to
minimize over time as much as possible
and fully staff represents me thank you
for that question so the 10
moves everybody 10 so the Gap that
exists today is now the same Gap at 10
higher what the intent of the footnote
on the bottom of hb12 uh page 12 hb2
page 12 lots of numbers and on how you
all do it I only have one budget
um is to say that we're trying to move
that base salary as allowed under
Personnel rule outside of bargaining so
that 10 percent will reflect off of that
base salary to commemorate a
competitiveness and to fix that chart
that I shared so I think that makes a a
certain significant Mark recognizing
that Corrections law enforcement is
different than it was several decades
ago and the 10 for All State agencies is
a value in keeping up with the community
I myself drove through
don't do this often a McDonald's to to
get something and Subs they offered 17
to 18 an hour when a corrections officer
at the time was making twenty dollars an
hour as a trainee we're not just
competing with law enforcement we're
competing with the community so we need
to shore up our state-based policies and
yeah go ahead thank you so I just have a
request for more information then can we
get the numbers of what the percent
increase would be or the hourly rate
increase would be if we were to include
the additional appropriation and then
the 10 across the board hike what that
would make the the pay for Corrections
Officers yeah representative Sweeney I'm
not sure if I can get you that answer
because the division of personnel is
literally going through those packets
and they make that determination but
I'll reach out and ask how close they
are to reviewing those appreciate it
thank you very much representative
Campbell
thank you Mr chair
um I know when I took the tour recently
that I believe it was a vacancy rate for
correctional officers of about 50 51 51
so obviously the overtime is killing you
because the are you what is the overtime
do they get double pay two and a half or
what what is the what is the rate they
get for overtime so there are two
different contracts that would govern um
they're multiple I have five contracts
because I have five different employees
the teamsters after 16 hours get double
the first 16 is time and a half after 16
is double there is some negotiation to
change that the sergeant Teamsters are
officers and corporals the sergeants and
above make time and a half
over 16 no the time and a half they
don't have the double time provision
um I believe what's before the
legislature should include a double time
provision for all overtime but I don't
want to speak for employee relations
um I want to share that we use our
Correctional line Personnel voluntarily
so some of their overtime is time and a
half some of their time is at straight
time and then our probation and parole
officers are at time and a half and they
also fill in the void so it's all hands
on deck at Corrections with every member
volunteering and or working a overtime
post so follow up so is it safe to say
that if you were able to fill the
positions full time we would actually
save money because the overtime costs
more absolutely to make up those hours
100 okay yeah
we want to reduce the overtime well but
I think a lot of it is stress right I
mean it's it's because you in some sense
you save on benefits because if you have
one person working overtime you don't
have two people collecting benefits but
anyways of the
975 six employees how many do you
actually have
I believe our fill rate's around 771 770
approximately 770 I'll get a firm number
you're about 200 Short yes wow
um an interesting comment on our
Correctional line Personnel we're
actually seeing a positive trend in
hiring
um that's interesting I haven't seen
that in a while but our law enforcement
ranks is the area of significant deficit
are you worse off in Concord or Berlin
Concord Berlin is actually uh if not
static slightly higher than they were
last year at this time still have needs
but they have not seen the hits in
Concord I see so you have openings
everywhere right openings everywhere we
gladly take your application and we uh
equal opportunity employers sir
yeah on page 13 I get a high level
overview of the budget book showing you
line by line comparatives by specific
class lines of significance I'm happy to
dive into any specific page you have a
question on the budget or other
questions relevant to the Department's
operational needs
so I remember when we were here last
time we talked about
rules that prevented you from
recognizing superiors
um
performance by employees or parties or
you know things like that did we ever
get any language to change that yes I
did send a language over to Mr Hoffman
I did email that to all the members of
The Division I can make photocopies
right now if you'd like it yeah why
yeah now I guess we've we've actually
gone through all of the House Bill 2
items right because that was part of
this presentation was there any should
we just look at the list just to make
sure
yeah why don't we kind of officially go
through the list and make sure there's
okay
yeah
I think they have hb2 so that's page
four
so this is something you always have is
that right
the
had that transfer Authority for uh at
least too much Cycles now yeah
and including the medical transfer
Authority new this year would be our ask
around coming back for utilities and
then again new is the three uh
unclassified positions that would
replace classified positions so it's an
equal transfer
and then the new ask is the three group
two positions and then again the cleanup
language that was not as successful as I
so any problem with 13
no okay
okay section 14. this is the
unclassified
so this is currently classified but not
becoming unclassified right
and going through the joint committee on
employee classifications under the
legislature
all right yeah okay third 14.
15.
oh this is the group two
for those three employees position types
and this is because they're they're
constantly with inmates yes they meet
the statutory definition of Correctional
line Personnel under the retirement law
all right
yeah okay
16.
the only thing there would be to ask
that you strike director of personnel
and information and director of
rehabilitative services that was the
goal just to streamline the sentence
because division directors would
Encompass those positions it does not
eliminate those positions
yeah this is just technical it's just
technical okay and the same in the
oh yep but it's two paragraphs Roman
numeral one and two would need the same
all right 17 okay 16 17.
well there's this new one right
oops
okay well this one obviously we're gonna
have to talk about later
yeah
right so 68 and 69 those are the 10 and
40 million I think
68 69.70
.
so we can't do those until we have
our whole numbers and 73 is the
okay
so that
um
yeah
and then uh 193 is the equity in
part-time officers getting the same pay
as Corrections Officers as well as
Corrections major being paid
commensurate with other leadership uh
security leadership
okay so that one 193. yeah
sorry to be slow here but did you say 73
and 74 were okay yes
so
.
right
yeah this one seems reasonable
to help you
get some more power time yes people okay
yeah right
okay was that it or was there more right
and then my additional and then request
obviously for you to discuss and
consider on the bottom there's a bit of
a line at The copier Janet's going to
bring that in as soon as you can
no such thing go ahead
just overall I'm I'm sure you've
considered
um other
correctional facilities for example I
know the Merrimack County Jail is great
and it's fairly new and I don't know
what their overtime situation is but if
they had the resources
is that an arrangement
that would be fiscally
a good one I mean I realize that's not
efficient I'm hearing your efficiency
argument
do you mean as a fiscal plant or do you
mean as a potential temporary place if
you don't if because 50 capacity of
Corrections Officers is crazy in my
opinion and it's probably hard for you
too probably harder for you
um
I don't know the capacity right now of
say any of our other correctional
facilities like Merrimack County jail
for instance
um it isn't that much further
uh
is that something that's ever been
considered to look at as a cost-saving
measure if they had the capacity because
I'd imagine it would be cheaper
in the short term to possibly pay them a
portion of what you would pay overall if
you don't have the Personnel capacity
so we house a project question makes
sense if you're talking about housing
people who are incarcerated at Merrimack
County Jail we have approximately uh one
thousand slightly it's approximately 1
200 men incarcerated the New Hampshire
state prison for men that doesn't fit
the capacity of the county jail county
jails are designed for short-term stays
one year or less so even their health
care infrastructure wouldn't meet our
needs we actually talked um we talked
off offline during the pandemic when
their housing sense is slow about
whether we would contract to house their
residents and have their employees come
in and manage their residence but we
have not been there's no physical jail
at this point that is large enough to do
what you're considering but we have
talked about it and we've even we've
even talked about can we recruit County
jail officers to come work for us some
of the disconnect just on the Staffing
side is they don't go through the same
Corrections Academy or have the same
minimum quals but that's not necessarily
a barrier and some of it is simply I
don't believe the county jail
superintendents want me to recruit their
employees
um and they were at one point had a very
significant vacancy rate and they I was
quite jealous when I read in the paper
the Belknap County Superintendent saying
you need five officers to Sure up his
Staffing I was very jealous I need like
205.
but it's a reasonable question
so Mike before we get to this new one
why don't we on page 12 of their today's
handout at the bottom uh representative
evil pointed out that this
um this is new language that they're
requesting what this was was
um the ability to go to the Department
of administrative services and
re-classify some of the lower level
corrections officer positions so that
they're paid a little better than fish
and game and some of these other
um
officers right or at least commensurate
with other uh
Junior officers right so
um what about what does the committee
okay
turn on your microphone
so remember we talked about this last
time we had we got a we had a chart of
all uh uniformed officers essentially
and it and and the the corrections
trainees were like the lowest paid
similar to fish and game this this thing
yeah it's similar to fish and game
trainees and so this is the thing to fix
that
because
at least in my mind those trainees have
a have a more stressful job than uh
other kinds of
officers right so yeah I would agree
with that yeah
yeah okay
so Mike can we figure out a place in
well first of all this language doesn't
yet have an RSA uh or maybe this is
chapter wide I don't know but figure out
where it goes I guess yes that would be
chapter well we we just add a new
section at the back and then when all of
us gets it they'll just use the next
number okay and it's modeled after
um language that was done for the state
troopers a few years ago great okay so
we're okay with this one yeah okay
all right now to this one
the one that was just tainted out
why don't you explain what you've done
certainly so in talking uh when we
talked last it's about how do we
um how do we continue to
recognize employees for Superior Service
or in this instance I would say the
number of hours that corrections
employees are engaging in overtime is a
superior service to the state so using
language that exists and will sunset
June 30 in 2023 through the previous
passage of some legislation I
recommended including in our specific
section a statute I have a division of
personnel and information they insert
new language to specifically Target one
week one week National correctionals
professional week and provide us the
opportunity to under the value of under
the value of 25
incentive performance incentives during
that week
and I add some explicit language on the
following page just trying to be mindful
of existing statutes and existing laws
that it would be for that exclusive
purpose only as a testing the waters of
the State trying to be a little more
nimble like the private sector but
and then noting that these types of
incentives are not collectively
bargained so they're not they're
something you earn they're a credit to
the work that you're doing on behalf of
I I'd looked at the average of 750
employees and spending thirty dollars on
each of them during that week that came
to a
sum total of twenty two thousand five
so that was the that was me being
um
so that that was recognition yes what is
but you're talking here about there's
some larger Statewide program that's
was passed with a sunset Clause so
through the state division of personnel
they have created uh more specifically
to Target the issues of Staffing
Recruitment and Retention those type of
incentives I'm asking for something
distinctly different but under the same
philosophy to Target recognition
and recognition as a part of retention I
think many of us know that but that
foundational elements started the
process of the things that you've likely
heard in the paper where if you're a new
corrections officer and you come to the
state of New Hampshire there's a
currently right now a ten thousand
dollar incentive payment the same is
true for state troopers trying to draw
people to law enforcement that's not
what I'm recommending moving forward
when that sunsets I'm recommending
something specific
during that National week that records
recognizes Corrections across the
country that a line item be created so
we can recognize and do Awards and gift
cards and simple gestures that go a long
way to our state employees working in
Corrections
okay
um
well I don't see any problem with that
um so will the
will the
Mike do we know if s if the Das is doing
something to replace SB 226
I don't believe so I just I think so it
wasn't a success it ends at the end of
did you use it at all or was it we uh
used it with regard to trying to shore
up our staff during the tough toughest
time so we had a two thousand dollar
retention incentive and then we have
that 10 000 we're trying to draw people
in as corrections officer the largest
Statewide initiative was an initiative
to award state employees who make a
referral for a new state employee that
period of supportive retention I would
call it and they each get a thousand
dollars and I think for a part-time they
each got a 500 so all of those things go
away on June 30
um and again I was looking to say what's
reasonable for an organization and this
was reasonable I think shuring up
people's wages is a way to rectify how
we've used uh the outcome of Senate Bill
226 but this is uh I think different
from that perspective and similar in the
intent which is to recognize employees
and focus on retention
yeah this is a much more minor type
thing right
any comments on this section
yes representative Schultz I'm just
obsessed with employee happiness it's a
hobby of mine actually in a research
topic I haven't making professional
sense
um
I think it could be interesting
to pull workers to see what incentives
during this time I Do by the way think
that the
referral fee and bonus thing is
definitely could be helpful but beyond
that I think it the things that
one might assume would be the best thing
that folks would want or that that would
make them that they would be most happy
with as even a prize for something isn't
always what we would assume it to be so
that's more of an editorial comment just
to say maybe that's an interesting thing
for your
stewards of your union or something to
poll members I don't know just putting
that out there
if we do this there's no chance we're
getting in trouble with any Union
contract by compensating somebody in a
way that the contract doesn't specify so
if you look at the highlight of I don't
know I think it's great insert new
you'll see that I included a section e
that balances exactly that
through you have to go through fiscal
committee before you is that what this
says I did replicate what has been the
process
I don't mind not going through fiscal
but I also uh I don't mind not having to
go through fiscal given that I only
asked for 22 500 and I
um if it was a larger amount I think if
the is it a hundred thousand dollars or
so maybe we'll take out that fiscal
committee section
um
that sentence Mike
so we're going to do this insert new
stuff in Gray here
except without the sentence about the
fiscal committee
because I think that this is right that
this is too small
yeah
I should have shot bigger I don't know I
was trying to be reasonable as usual
yeah it's a place to begin right that's
the waters
thank you for that support
um
in Roman numeral three trying to
recognize uh the tragic lightning
strikes our agency experiences and what
I've had to go through as a commissioner
and giving me some Authority within my
agency to help
um if we have another tragic event and
the resources are not available to help
so this is to insert some new powers
under statute that do have a cost
associated with it out of the duties of
the commissioner this language is
similar to language under the Department
of Labor associative workman's comp
claims and opportunities there but it is
really a
a tragic response to his experience
we've we've gone through
go ahead and representative are any of
the corrections agents are under there
is a new sort of trend among certain
segments of state employees it started
with
First Responders I realized maybe
Corrections isn't under that of a
one-time a hundred thousand dollar death
benefit if they die on the line of duty
and it has since added additional
categories
um School Employees Public School
Employees and now Public Works employees
um
have you paid attention to that and
I can't imagine that wouldn't be
something you wouldn't want but is have
you paid attention to that evolution of
that discussion and might that be better
representative Schultz I appreciate that
question and yes I have engaged in that
and that I was a part of the reason that
statute changed to include Corrections
Officers and probation and parole
officers that's a 100 000 payment to
next to Kin if it's determined after 180
days to be a line of duty death this was
a ask for a more immediate response
during the death
um that I shall have the power to do
that if it's appropriate
yeah yeah I guess I'm I'm not in favor
of this one we have a bill
along these lines right so
um maybe which is more general for all
police and fire in the state I think
um and that would include it's
essentially for all group two right so I
think that would cover these if
you know so we have we're considering
this kind of thing in a different way
okay
um there are also Federal benefits that
I I think apply there's there is a
federal one-time benefit in these cases
yeah this was more of uh literally
somebody has passed and there is a need
uh in less than seven days to in turn
and always cover burial expenses that's
why the amounts not to exceed ten
thousand dollars yeah it's literally
specific to pay burial and week expenses
I mean you could think of it at that
hundred thousand dollars you know ten
thousand of it could come early for this
if needed for the burial
I just don't feel comfortable doing it
for this department and not that
department and you know you see what I
mean it's
could we just like set it aside and see
what happens with the other insurance
we're working on yeah
yeah it's um I would hope that I never
made yeah and the other one navigate
that again
so
so the other interesting thing about
that other bill
um
was it two is this it 250 yeah
is
according to the fiscal note it doesn't
apply to existing spouses who are in
this situation right and apparently
there's there's uh there's 20 of them or
so something like that
um 19.
and surprisingly to me actually only
seven police and twelve fire I I had
always thought it'd be the other way
around
um but but but according to this the
bill is only prospective right for new
deaths on duty
not for
um not for those 19 existing so the
amount the same ten thousand dollars no
no this is it's it's similar but it's
not the same it this is about ongoing
compensation for surviving spouses
that's that's different though that's
that is
this is the there's a one-time benefit
for that's for next again this is for
the immediate family one-time benefit to
Barry and I can tell you quite frankly
ten thousand dollars won't even do the
job according to this
um RSA 21i 29a
gives a 100
000 lump sum benefit so that already is
there
right
so
you know there's already a one hundred
thousand and I was very involved in the
second and the third rounds of these
discussions on the other agencies and
I'll just say part of that was to help
earlier than the existing ongoing system
especially uh workers comp will be
involved it's above and beyond that it
was supposed to be the early
safety net that would include expenses
like this but she's rated you know I'm
pretty sure they all all three of those
have
um you know because there's you have to
make the determination officially in
each case a commissioner is in charge of
making that decision if if that worker
you know qualifies
um and then that's 180 days it's 180
days from the request for the review so
this language that I proposed here was
not to give money
to the next of kin but to work with the
next of kin to pay up to ten thousand
dollars for the burial and wake Services
because it again
I say this carefully hoping to never
have this tragic experience again we
needed something in less than seven days
and the existing statutes had I not been
engaged in changing it didn't include a
broad definition of law enforcement so
there was debate because there were
specific terms police firemen that's a
blending of First Responders and police
officers but if you use the definition
under 106l certified law enforcement you
will always include Corrections Officers
and probation and parole officers when
the language starts to get specific it
excludes groups that you would
inherently had hoped potentially to
include so again this was an attempt to
say in the worst and hopefully rarest of
instances that the commissioner of
Corrections shall have the discretion to
pay burial and wake services not to
exceed that thousand dollars again if if
that tragedy strikes and the next of Ken
demonstrates demonstrates an inability
to afford the burial or wake expenses
not to give them a
not to give them a lump sum to live off
of in compensation but to pay the
respects to the employee who died
suddenly tragically and unfortunately
um for their services and I just want to
make a caveat the department pays for
the burial services of an Indigent
prisoner but I had no path forward to
pay for someone who didn't have and I'm
not blaming the person they didn't they
were very young and no one necessarily
thinks of this lightning strike and we
absolutely engaged in donations and
everything else you would expect but I
think again this is just a respectful
nod to say that lightning strike happens
that
right but the point is you know state
troopers need this and commissioner
correction sir I'm advocating for the
commissioner so that's my point I think
this should be a different bill is what
I think I don't think it's the kind of
thing we can do okay in two weeks in the
budget but that's my opinion uh
committee you may or may not agree yes
you don't mind me asking well um
what in a way that is fair and what
would be the classification of the
worker who passed and what was their
what were their wages at the time
because I bet it's a lot lower than a
State Trooper but I don't know the
answer
uh I didn't go through the analysis of
their wages I went through the analysis
of how much would it cost at the next of
kin couldn't pay and to represent
Gabriel's point this would be a
yep I guess representative evil would
like to come well I just wondered if we
one okay all right so this is
um
the question is do we want to let's see
where is this number three yes okay
Roman numeral three on the bottom of the
second page
um honor of Fallen officer the
commissioner shall have the power to
determine
um at the commissioner's discretion to
pay burial and wake expenses not to
exceed ten thousand dollars for an
employee whose death occurs while on
duty with the department and when the
next of kin demonstrates an inability to
afford the burial or wake expenses
all right so all those in favor of this
okay it looks like six to one okay
um
what's the historic trend on
Correctional deficits dying on duty
fortunately not significant but I have
had
um I've had
a two now two now and I had one officer
early on who was actually peddling to
work who was struck by a van and killed
on the way to work uh Sergeant Pat
bettens
so it's not frequent sir
again a rare but tragic event that I
want anyone who's in this position to be
prepared for
so the more officers work for you than
for any other department yes sir I have
the technically largest law enforcement
agency because I have probation and
parole officers Corrections Officers and
one could opine and I also have
Correctional line Personnel who are
group two law enforcement retirees
gotcha okay
all right anything further for
Department of Correction
thank you thank you very much
and your support and um let's move on to
uh I guess the parole board is here
again
is there more to talk about or
I thought we we finished that last night
all right
so somehow it seems like you were just
here and and we uh
uh we we learned
what's going on so you have um six
employees
is it it's five of you plus one uh one
secretary or something like that is it
included oh okay okay these are uh the
parole staff uh I should introduce
myself I'm Roger Phillips thank you
chairperson of the adult parole board
and with me is our director of operation
Jade Mackey
uh on my left
the budget that was submitted uh and it
is before he was pretty much as we had
requested we had asked for to prioritize
needs
initially but last
Friday you addressed those in with the
with the
thank you very much with the ought to
pass of Bill 504
but I'm here today to ask of the sixth
employees in the
parole office
to our unclassified and four
are classified and I'm going I'm asking
for a fifth classified employee
we
drastically need
an additional CCM uh
Corrections case manager to assist us in
putting together the parole packets
um
we'll have to explain a little bit when
we digitally uh went through got rid of
all our paper products and then now can
do a digital presentation so that we all
have our uh laptops and and that
material is is available for board
members
the the parole packet begins two weeks
before the hearing date
and it takes almost that entire two-week
time to fully prepare the packet there
are some 23 different areas that have to
be addressed in it
since I went on the board in 2019 that
job has been done by two different
individuals uh uh two of whom have left
the uh the department because of stress
uh it's in a very stressful job to put
this together
and we have a CCM now that's doing it it
does a remarkable job but it's very
difficult to do all of those parole
it because of all of that increased work
we would ask for an additional CCM to a
assist in that
he or she would also be able to assist
for revocation uh matters
and would also free up the time
for the director of operations so that
he wouldn't have to do some of these
things and could do the duties that he
really
ought to be would be be doing uh so that
we could keep better statistics better
track of things so that we we know right
now what in a uh six we know right now
with in a six-person Department it's
very difficult to do all that's required
and I think we're
extremely pleased with the talent that
we have
and certainly want to keep them but I
certainly because of the really the high
stress job I would request that approval
so in the handout today is the the cost
of of of doing that uh adding the
additional so you saying it um and I
would hope the committee would
approve our request so we could add that
to the budget
so you you gave this request to the
governor presumably and he said we said
no we we did and it was a prioritized
need that we we requested
um I recognized that the governor want
did not want to increase the number of
employees but quite frankly this is a
public safety issue we want to make
certain that there is a enough
information in those packets so that we
make good decisions uh and you know a
lot of the few years ago requested that
we have more information
but it took it takes a lot of
preparation to put that together and
it's a very stressful time I don't know
if the director of operation wants to
add anything to that or not but it it it
it takes a lot of time yeah I can I can
have some more um just so identify
yourself I'm sorry oh sorry j Mackey
director of operations for the pool
board
j h a y Mackey m-a-c-k-e-y
now I've been supervising this office
for almost two years now July will be
two years
um
the current case manager that we do have
like like uh Roger says does a fantastic
job
um and I I've been in with the doc since
2016. so I've known all the people that
have worked in that office since before
I I got into the office and I've seen
all the stress that they've gone through
the one the more recent cccm that left
is still a case manager just in a
different area now he's working he's
back with the doc with in a halfway
house and and loving it more than what
he did prior to but in addition to
preparing for the parole hearings the
case manager also sits in on the parole
hearings like a court monitor does and
takes down all the notes and results of
all that so one day a week that person
at least one day a week that person is
away from their desk and unable to
provide all all that information for the
upcoming hearings
um
he's also in charge of the interstate
transfer process called icots where
people are applying to have their parole
supervision done in another state he's
responsible for getting all that
application work done which is time
consuming because you need the uh you
need the police reports from the
prosecuting agency which is always the
biggest one that takes a lot of time
like we just had an issue with the AG's
office and so we had to actually talk
have a nice little talk with them and
they understood the process oh we'll get
them to you right now that individual
waited like two months to be released
because of that but that's just added
added duties on top of preparing for
parole packets that this individual does
um having that second case manager it
will have the trickle-down effectives
the supervisor in the office the
supervisor for
is the one that covers all the
revocation hearings now and does the
schedule and all that stuff whereas the
second case manager can do that so she
can have more of a role of the
supervisory duties that are in her job
description
which will then again will have an
effect on the amount of Duties that I'm
doing that are duties within the office
day-to-day duties that where could be
taken off of my plate that will free me
up to do as Roger said a lot of the Data
Tracking
um looking at the best practices among
the among the other states and how we
are falling into line with the national
averages and and stuff that um I know
like I know there's a bill right now to
um
to track the long-term impact of the New
Hampshire parole system and that's
something I've been trying to do but
unfortunately we don't have enough staff
questions representative Griffin
thank you Mr chair thank you for
answering the question
um
you both talked about stress in this
particular job how does it differ from
the stress any other secretary or any
other
uh person
in a similar job
would have
okay thank you for the question
representative Griffin
um so I've been in Corrections for 24
years I was an officer as well as a
field training officer team member then
when I became supervisory you know onto
the civilian side so I I've the stress
kind of increases the higher you go I
can completely understand that what we
have is a lot of timelines that need by
Statute that we need to have things done
by with within the office like when you
talk about vacation areas we got to have
hearings within 45 days of their arrest
and we have we rely on other divisions
other agencies to let us know when
somebody's incarcerated so we can get
them transported to the prison to fall
into this guideline
excuse me we have our our own
administrative rules where we have to
have somebody
um shall have a parole hearing within 60
days of their minimum parole date so we
have
um between that we have as soon as they
are approved parole we send out the home
plans as part of the case manager's jobs
has sent out the home plan to give to
field services to investigate Say by
policy 15 days to investigate that to
provide a response to see if this person
is going to be able to live at that
address so a lot of the stuff we do is
Guided by timelines which adds to the
stress factor but just the sheer volume
of work in itself
is mainly the stress factor
we don't want to keep people any longer
than they're supposed to be kept so
that's
so you you talked about 23 items in a
packet but it seemed I don't quite
understand that because it seems to me
somebody who's sentenced to prison and
the day they're sentenced they have a
whole court record and and so on right I
mean there's some big judicial record of
why you know what happened to them and
how they got into prison and then from
that point
they have
however they behave while they're in
prison right so presumably everybody has
a file and when things happen it goes in
that file so what what more than those
two sets of Records
are involved well a good deal of it
um
yes the the Senate saying the the actual
we have to have copies of the actual
indictments and the sentencing records
the the Minimus
and then of course when they arrive we
have the face sheet so we know when
their minimum parole date is whether or
not they owe restitution whether or not
they owe attorney's fees there are all
sorts of issues uh including whether or
not they have any pending legal matters
but
there's a our system is the chorus
system that has to be accessed to find
out everything from their disciplinary
um not only their their disciplines but
of course all of the courses that
they've taken all of the prop progress
they've made were also issues such as
how they did in Focus or how they did it
in a particular matter what kind of
Aftercare is required but when putting
all of this together it's not a you know
it's in the chorus system but it's not
easily located so it has to be taken out
and then put separate into this digital
package
um so that we we have that you know and
then there are other things like the
resident release synopsis which the CCM
the case manager for the individual
resident in the in the prison prepares
along with the parole application
um
um they're but if we go through all of
these different steps that has to be
done for all
15 to 18
Parolees that are going to come up for
that hearing uh in in two weeks and it
takes time to do that at the same time
people with they have to get a hold of
the health services so we we have
behavioral health records we have to
know what recommendations are are made
along those lines too for instance
whether a person is unrequired
psychiatric medications or is it
required or is on a mat program so that
there's treatment for his or her
addiction all of these things
go into our digital package but it's
time consuming to do that and often as a
pro board member sometimes I we don't
get all of this information until the
day before hearing and that's that's
probably why it's so stressful because
there are lots of moving Parts you know
the individuals filling out the
application doesn't get to his case
manager uh the person who's doing the
behavioral health summary
because they're they need more Personnel
they don't get to do it uh that two-page
summary or three-page summary until the
last minute and so oftentimes we are
reading things the day of the Pearl
hearing rather than having the time to
fully go go through it the way I'd like
to
so that's really where this where the
stress is because there's a lot of what
the course is an old system
um and it I wish it would as simple as
you you could just go into it and
readily find things but it often
takes time to even you know enter it and
then search it and then get to where you
want and then copy it so it's like when
did that explanation but that that's
what the what the issue is any other
questions from the committee
no
yes representative cameras thank you
thank you Mr chair uh what would you say
is the average time it would take to
prepare one packet just so we can do
some numbers here well we know that it
it
it takes almost that full two weeks time
to uh I know that that our president CCM
starts
um the Friday before the
the two-week carrying day
um and that's on on a Thursday and he
likes to get everything done by the
Tuesday of that week because then
everything has to be scanned and put in
the packets and get into the system so
that the pro board members can access it
um
I know he said to do
that it takes almost that entire
two-week time period to prepare all well
I don't think it
it's never done packet by packet it's
done the first I think he starts off
first by going into the system to get
the indictments and the bit of Misses
that's the first the way each stats are
and while you're in there you want to
get them for all of the people later on
uh you don't do it one at a time but
when you're into the system you want to
get as many as you can and get them
copied it out
so I don't understand the way you're
saying this there's one person doing
this yes correct so what are the other
three employees doing
well they're
I think our director can answer that
better so yes uh the one unclassified
position other than me is a part-time
secretary and she is the one doing most
of the scanning of everything
um of all the pro package for both
parole and revocation hearings our
executive secretary is the one who
schedules everyone out for release
which she tends to release anywhere from
well at least it used to be having done
those statistics lately but I know we
don't let her do more than 10 in a day
because that puts a lot of pressure on
all the other divisions to prepare
people for Relief so we try to schedule
them out as best as we can but she's
scheduling people for release every day
we have a new uh secretary too who's
being trained on doing all the parole
scheduling which I had to take over when
we when our secretary had retired
um but her main function is is doing all
the parole hearing schedules
um as well as a lot of the home plan
stuff sending out Home Plans getting the
responses in to give when they're
approved to give to the executive
secretary who then reviews everything
for release
um so each person has basically their
own set of duties
but since we've had multiple people be
out for like right now they're
supervisor four four is out and we're
covering all the revocation stuff for
her uh we all know how to do each
other's jobs
um very a lot more stressful when one
person is out for an extended period of
time she's now in our third week which
she's supposed to be kept coming back
next week which is fantastic but
um
in addition to with just to give you an
idea uh parole packet is usually
anywhere from 30 to 60 pages long
um and that just kind of more depends on
the length of time that person has
served in the prison as well as just
their own behaviors and and all that
other types of stuff
now there's you're releasing roughly 10
people a week is that right
I'll have to look I want I wanted to
start looking at that again since the
the numbers have gone down so much over
the last few years but there was a time
before when I was used to work in
another division that they would tell
her not to do more than 10 in a day like
a schedule they schedule them three to
four days out or at least so we have
somebody we know can't leave until March
14th
but everything is squared away she might
on today send out the notice that he's
being released next Tuesday no
um
I wanted I haven't been able to do the
date on how many releases we've done
over the past year which is one of the
things I wanted to get done I just have
in my mind that you're doing 15 hearings
a week right and for parole for parole
what's a revocation that's when uh
when someone who's already on parole
goes out and violates the parole rules
and regulations or sometimes commits a
crime and then a warrant has to be
prepared and then a warrant is issued
and then within 45 days of their arrest
there must be a due process hearing so
the
revocation hearings are held on Tuesdays
of every week
and the parole hearings are held on
Thursday for instance that CCM who's
doing the parole packets sits the other
CCM is out on leave
must come in on every Tuesday so he
loses a whole day there uh doing the the
but in any case the parole hearings 15 a
week you approve 70 percent so that's
roughly 10 or 11. something like that
correct yeah generally generally yeah
we don't really have our
uh
I don't know our requirements and so
maybe we should keep this
perfect
things that if you have an extra hundred
thousand
that's right
yeah
so if someone is on parole and they have
to do periodic check-ins who are they
checking in with with the probation
parole officers okay who they're they're
okay I just wondered
of the Department of Corrections right
and my other question as the clerk
because I stepped outside
could you just give me your name
I'm Roger Phillips Phillips okay with a
double L
thank you okay
our probation officers officers group
New Hampshire
so in Massachusetts probation officer is
another person and our state the
information and parole officers with a
singular person
employees
okay
all right yes uh my
just a clarification is the
complete Budget on hold or just the
additional position request
yeah just the additional position right
I don't think we have any do we have any
problem with the existing budget as set
by the governor no right
huh
at this point I don't think we know
exactly where we're at we know we know
we gotta uh we gotta find some money
yeah or something to meet the budget
the revenue projections were not what we
expected
representative Schultz I realize I'm the
clueless not Committee Member here but
it sounds like some of this role would
save money in the long run if someone is
waiting to be
released from prison you know and they
have to wait because they don't have the
Staffing I wonder if that pays for
itself
do you want to comment on them
well that sort of is yeah well that's
true I mean obviously we want to meet a
due process requirements
um and we want to make sure that we have
all the information available and not
continue a hearing
so that's
yes people
and and I know sometimes the Department
of Corrections would love to see more
paroled but we want to make sure that
paroled successfully so that's the
that's our goal and that's why we're an
independent quasi-judicial agent agency
just to make that decision so that we
can add puts in the message is not only
of the parolee but of the citizens of
Sweeney sorry I figured I should ask
while I have you here so we did have on
Friday we had 504 that would do the uh
increases to the Commissioners 51 500
per year we have this additional request
for 83 000 in the first year and 87 000
in the second year correct if we had to
prioritize I know it's the worst
question to be asked if you had to
choose one or the other which would you
choose well it's difficult too because
what happens if we don't have the packet
the people that you just gave the raise
so can't review
on on the other hand if you have the
packet that we lose for old board
members then we're not going to have
anyone to review those packets so it
really goes hand in hand thank you I
I tried to but the only thing I'd be
willing to give up is calling on a prior
board member to sit but that's only a
1500 item
yeah
I mean
let me talk about it this way the number
of of inmates is going down
so therefore I would assume your work is
the population I I think it was
remaining pretty close to 2000. our
people are qualifying for some parole
hearings more quickly so we're doing
about the same number of parole hearing
as we were before
but
see the
um three and a half to seven year
sentences we're seeing a lot of one to
five year sentences a one to four year
sentences sometimes they're violations
of probations uh because they're they're
placed
back in in prison because they violated
the give the drug court or something
else so actually the the number of
herrings I I think it would uh are going
to remain pretty steady it'll be about
1400 a year uh between
thank you very much thank you very much
I appreciate it
shall we get started
this budget starts on the bottom of page
14.
and goes through Page 18. it's within
so do we generally not look at the
governor's
budget itself
Pages 12
Etc that's correct no good yeah
just like we don't look at the
legislative but
[Laughter]
unlimited funds all right so um page 14
commissioner
[Music]
okay
all right thank you please
um introduce yourself
to my left is the what we refer to as
the gcd the gcd's business administrator
could you spell the last name d as in
um
all right shall we go go through your
presentation yeah if that if that would
please you uh Mr chair so I have we have
put together a PowerPoint
um it's a robust PowerPoint and in the
interest of um time what I can do is
take you through the pages which I
believe are most relevant for today's
hearing obviously with a focus on the
budget
um
so we can start on page one and when we
look at the governor's Commission on
disability from a from a from the
substantive nature of what it does on a
regular basis it's all about the
Americans with Disabilities Act
um the Americans with Disabilities Act
also known as the Ada was a piece of
federal legislation passed in 1990
um the picture there is with President
George H.W bush signing the Ada into law
on July 26th and essentially the Ada is
a civil rights law
that prohibits discrimination based on a
disability so on a regular basis we look
at the Ada and we try to assist the
constituents of the State of New
Hampshire
under the Ada there are certain titles
there's title one which deals with the
employment of individuals with
disabilities Title II which applies the
Ada to State and local governments and
title III which is public accommodations
essentially if you're a private business
a hotel a restaurant the law office
whatever it may be if it's open to the
public it's subject to the Ada also as a
as a piece of federal legislation so on
a regular basis that's what the gcd does
I I think Mr Chia you had referenced our
agency is Right within the governor's
office so when we look at the statutory
structure of the gcd that's where we are
not physically but it's uh it's within
on the budget on page two
the gcd is made up of an executive
director and sitting side by side to the
executive director is the commission
members which uh Governor appointed
commission members of which we have 17
of them and there are six statutorily
assigned ex-official members I'm
comprising various commissioners of
state government
and on page three that is our org chart
and the gcd we already I say this often
and we are a smaller Agency for the
State of New Hampshire but as we all
know there are a good amount of small
agencies in New Hampshire we are
comprised of seven individuals that
actually out of staff and you know if I
could have the opportunity to say a
special thanks to my entire staff on a
regular basis they they obviously do the
the the subject matter uh heavy lift in
dealing with the constituents um for the
State of New Hampshire
um let me ask you a question so I'm
looking on page 18 of the budget and it
looks to me like you have six
am I looking on the wrong thing six not
seven uh because if I'm not mistaken it
doesn't the budget doesn't account for a
part-time employee so out of that seven
there is one part-time employee I should
have clarified that I apologize thank
you yeah sure
um on page four again we um we serve as
a source of information
uh a source of research and our job is
to advise the governor the New Hampshire
legislature other state agencies as it
deals with the Ada on a regular basis
and we ensure in what we try to do is we
really strive for collaboration among
state government I've always held the
position and and it's really a core of
the gcd we all play on the same team and
it's important to look at that and
really to look at the state agencies and
if they have a question about the Ada
call on us and we'll see what we can do
to assist
um so that is Page four
um again these are some of the core
functions we admit as um as an agency we
administer
um on page five the New Hampshire able
savings account which has been
authorized by 195 RSA 195k under the
statute the state treasurer and the
executive director of the governance
command mission on disability administ
this this program we can get into that a
little bit later very similar to college
savings plans for individuals with a
disability we Implement 100 federally
funded client assistance program again
that deals with Title One Employment of
the Ada we administer the our the
Telecommunications equipment assistance
program known as teep which is funded by
the puc on page six we receive an annual
appropriation
statutorily to fund nfb newsline which
ensure that individuals who may have a
disability and which rent is that they
can't read the printed word this is like
a a reader for them
there is a statutory committee known as
the architectural barrier for design
committee which opines on physical
accessibility in private
companies as well as state government
and we house an independent living
Council
with funding from the Department of
Education
what we have seen and I think you all
know in in order to get the word out in
order to really deal with the consent to
to give the information to the
constituents of New Hampshire we have a
very robust social media presence both
on Facebook and Twitter we're in the
process of updating our website now
because again with with a smaller office
and with limited bandwidth whatever we
have to do to get the information out if
we can do it in a sense that is free
till for lack of a better term we we
look at it as a a practical no cost
option um for collaboration and I must I
do have to really emphasize when it
comes to social media it really is
having a social media committee a group
that we have internally that meets on a
weekly basis we're not just posting for
the sake of posting where it's really a
deliberate attempt to get the needed
information out and to look what is
going on
um in the com in the community
and page eight goes over some of the
resources I won't get into the details
and some of the various committees that
we have been assigned to
um page nine really looks at three of
the positions at the gcd one is the
accessibility specialist
that position is vacant right now it's
been vacant for um since September and
the accessibility specialist looks at
what we refer to the as the physical
environment
to see if it's in in compliance with the
2010 Ada standards for accessible design
the lack of a better explanation does a
bathroom need a grab bar
does they have to be a ramp all of the
necessary regulations the title One
Employment Specialist works right within
the realm of an individual with a
disability either currently working in
requesting possible accommodations such
as let's say a screen reader if a person
is blind or vision impaired so the title
One Employment Specialist is
consistently working with employment
matters and our research and information
Specialists as the individual that takes
in the vast majority of the calls that
come in
we keep an internal log that we will go
over on page next page on page 10. the
one you know the top three calls that we
get deal with service animals and those
come from individuals who own service
animals from businesses that are asking
the question is it a service animal
um the another a major component of the
log and the calls that we get on a
regular basis deal with the American
Americans with Disabilities Act in
reasonable accommodation requests and
also building compliance as I said so
those are the top three calls that come
into that we're comp continually
um
working with in all of the positions
that I mentioned on page nine what you
see is a collaboration with state
government for example the accessibility
specialist will work with the Department
of administrative Services may work with
HHS if HHS is thinking of entering into
a lease a third-party lease to open up a
satellite office
the Employment Specialist will work with
other entities or bureaus over at HHS
and research and information has a
direct Pipeline and consistently works
with the governor's office his office of
constituent services
so with that we can
jump to page 13
which essentially will go over what our
budget is all about and I and I know
that's the really what we're trying to
focus on for today
um again as stated we respectfully
submit that the continued adequate
funding of the governance Commission on
disability is essential to ensure the
mandates delegated to the gcd
um also the gov we suggest that the
governor's recommended budget in each
year
um is in line with the FY 22 actuals and
23 adjusted authorized
and on page 14
this is
um basically goes over the target we
were able to hit the target in both
years of the biennium
we were
um and correct me if I'm wrong Stacy
um we were just 35 000 under
um within the target
um for FY 24 and 35
000 in FY 25.
um so that is truly substantially lower
than what the governor had requested at
the governor's face
um coupled with that there is a an
additional prioritized needs request
that's built into that and we
respectfully are requesting a part-time
position at the gcd
um when we go to what the APN actually
comes down to
at the end of the day and with no
disrespect intended we would go over the
Target by 6 000 and FY 24 and 7 000 um
in fy25 so on page 15
um that actually breaks down the salary
for the um part-timer in
24 it would come to Thirty One Thousand
four twenty seven
benefits would come to 25.87 and the
additional laptop and software is just
under 4 000 so it's a request of 37 980
for that position and an FY 25 it would
be 37 144. there are other prioritized
needs requests that I'm requesting on
behalf of doit that actually had come
into our budget exclusive of our
additional prioritized needs requests to
the tune of about 3 200 in FY 24 in
almost 3 400 in fy25
so on page 16 is a little bit about the
Ada coordinator
just by way of background to to let you
if I could explain to you where this
request is coming from
um a few years back
um in working with the governor's office
there was a request by constituents to
look at the rates of the hiring of
individuals with disabilities just
Across the Nation
um and the gcd formed itself into an
internal committee and we put together
what was known as the workforce focus
group and at the table where consumers
other New Hampshire state agencies and
and we what we tried to do is to look at
um how what the hiring practices were
for the State of New Hampshire and
whatever we can do to make it better
because I think at the end of the day we
can always make everything a bit better
one of the recommendations that came out
of the workforce focus group was to
perhaps have an ADA coordinator a person
who could sit in a position that if an
individual is gainfully employed by the
state of New Hampshire and that person
has a disability
during their tenure ship of employment
there are requests that may come up what
we refer to as accommodations
what we see in in state agencies and
this is just across the country
the traditional HR person may not be as
versed in Ada matters as others May so
we looked at it and said maybe to have
this person sit at the gcd with close
collaboration with the division of
personnel to get to to assist agencies
and in navigating these waters I'll be
the first to admit when when you're a
supervisor when you're an employee if if
that isn't your subject matter I don't
want to use the word expertise but even
exposure traditional HR it can be
somewhat trying so we looked at this as
a as an opportunity again to bring the
state together to work together so that
was the request we have and that's why
it's a request for a part-time position
um in both um in both years the rest of
the bullets are on page 16 deal with
um again we envision working with DLP
luckily we actually are tenants of 54
Regional Drive where the division of
personnel is located so we're in the
same building right now with Personnel
so we have a great relationship
um with them so you know this for me and
I'm containing my my excitement this is
a good opportunity I would say you know
there are principles across the country
known as same state as model employer
and at the end of the day I think that's
what we all want we want the state of
New Hampshire as with all uh even
private sector to be a model employer
and this is this is leaning in that
direction
um so your your consideration for that
request is is truly greatly appreciated
other than that that's the PowerPoint I
didn't want to give too deep a dive but
I'm more than happy to answer questions
directly on the budget or any of the
yes let's go to page 19 of the budget
which is your bottom line yes
um
so you you spent considerably
less
wait a minute I'm on the wrong sorry
it's page 18. sorry page 18. you've
spent considerably less in fiscal year
22 than than any of the numbers going
forward so in general funds you spent
360 then a five 358
yeah so 358 000 as opposed to these 500
Plus numbers
okay hey Jay team of the budget okay
yeah and that's um in other words if I
may miss the chair just to clarify so
we're looking at actuals of 357 904 and
then I have an adjusted authorized 536
and then the recommended of 558 893.
now if I may
ask Stacy a question to ensure the 558
does that include client assistance and
silk
performance no the 558 is just for I
think the biggest one for for fiscal
year 2022 we had two vacancies one of
them was bacon I think the whole year
this accessibility specialist I think
that
is perhaps a good portion of it
is that an unclassified position no
that's a classified position in class 10
so that was vacant for quite some time
and so was the um
the
secretary the admin secretary so we were
down position for for a while that and
she's which are now filled uh one is
filled and one is not filled that's the
one that we're posting right now and
it's been it's been vacant since
September gotcha Now You're Expecting
well I think it's it depends the the gcd
is made up of two accounting units so we
have one zero zero four and one zero
zero six one zero zero six is a hundred
percent Federal uh to the tune of about
a lot right so that that continues
forward for that accounting unit and the
one individual one classified individual
that is in that program and built within
one zero zero four is we do receive
funds from the Department of Education
um or
for silk and the amount I think the
total appropriation is ninety thousand
yes
and that is in our so in other words
when we look at one zero zero four Mr
chair the funds coming from the state of
New Hampshire Department of Education
are already in those numbers that we
would have to break down for you
okay
all right so mainly it's unfilled
positions yeah there is um one part-time
in the
Federal funding program
as well that was not felt in the in the
it's not filled now and it wasn't until
right and the other accountant unit one
zero zero six which is the Federal which
is 100 Federal okay and the other funds
is this the Department of Education
sure we receive um there's an
appropriation from the puc
um of 96 000 per year per statute to run
the Telecommunications equipment
assistance program the funds from the
puc and not General funds they come from
the relay service trust fund and those
funds are garnished from what they call
land provide is local Access Network
VoIP providers basically the telephone
company and whoever's provides so they
get that money in the trust fund 96 000
comes over to governance Commission on
disability to run that program we put it
out to an RFP every two years and they
also fund newsline for the blind to the
tune of about is it 31.5 31 500 which is
included in there also thank you
questions from the community
I want to
I don't know if I have the doit with me
so I apologize for that representative
um
if I'm I don't think that if I may I
don't think that that built in any um
equipment that was the other fees to
support the gcd if I'm not mistaken yeah
the only we do have equipment but that's
in typically in the efficiency budget
um but the other
let me just look back are you asking
about so in other words page 17. so the
31 51 and 33.81 okay so basically if you
look at the Ada coordinator the laptop
um that is class 27 as well and that's
for a new laptop monitors
um any additional
licenses it needs for for the laptop
and whatnot those I believe are numbers
that we received from doit and then the
line number two is not any appointment
on our par it's for
um
their services for the services provided
from doit to support the gcd
but would we need those
only with if we take the Ada coordinator
or or do we need those always
if I'm not mistaken correct me if I'm
wrong the 3151 is exclusive of the Ada
coordinator
or does that including Ada coordinate
that's exclusive exclusive so the 3151
Mr chair in the 3381 in class 27
prioritized needs are exclusive of ADA
coordinator
they asked us to put it in our budget
because for their additional costs
basically
okay but the governor didn't want to
spend it
um he he funded funded them in the
governor's budget if I'm not yes I'm
pretty sure it's in the governor's
recommended if I'm not mistaken okay
but the Ada coordinator is not it is
asked for from him
go ahead don't know you're right sorry
essentially you're correct ever the APNs
were approved by uh the governor and his
budget director so they are in the
governor's recommended budget
I figured when we put the PowerPoint
together that I should break it down for
thank you other questions representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chair thank you
both for being here for the work you do
I'm I'm going to and this might be
dangerous to make the assumption that
there are more federal funds out there
uh for Disabilities than 164 000. does
that get routed to Health and Human
Services and not go through your
commission do you have any sort of
interface with Health and Human Services
on that just because I would imagine it
would be substantially more yeah that
that's a great question representative
um there are more funds um the funds
that we receive from the federal
government uh from the rehabilitation
services Administration Administration
RSA and it's specifically for
um the items that I spoke about
employment so the other if there are any
direct if there are monies for Direct
Services perhaps those are and I I don't
know assuming it goes to HHS because
they're they're able to then put it into
say Bureau developmental Services as an
example over the years I've been in this
position for a bit we we have looked at
federal funds because I honestly if
they're out there I'd love to apply for
them we have over the years applied a
couple times we've tried to bring in
collaborators from the state because we
don't traditionally have the incredible
bandwidth but we have looked in the past
for those funds so I should also say
that the silk funds are federal funds
but they are collected from
right there so she so the the funds that
come in for our part-time person we we
build New Hampshire Department of
Education ultimately when you Source
those funds those are federal to doe and
then doe under contract with gcd
I I don't know if that helps out
so any other questions no
shall we just simply approve the
governor's budget in this case yeah yes
representative evil I just want to make
absolutely I'm clear the prioritized
needs that you spelled out in this are
included in the governor's budget
yes why don't we double why don't we
double check explaining what they were
yeah so a lot of times people
they aren't included yeah so I I
apologize my goal was not to confuse
that's right I thought it may have
behooved this honorable committee to
break down what the request was so that
I but yes everything is included in the
governor with the efficiency budget and
the prioritizing needs so so our
efficiency budget was quite a bit less
than our Target and then with our
prioritized needs which includes the Ada
um the Ada coordinator it was part-time
yeah it was part-time
um
and the other
items listed on the next page 15.
um
that made us a slightly over Target but
the governor ultimately approved him and
if you looked at the total request of
552 882 for fiscal year 24.
um that is the same amount as the
governor's project right and just to be
on the safe side yes yeah when I look at
page 15 if I may I don't mean to
interrupt so I look at the class 50.
because we already have a class 50 and
we see it at roughly 26 000 and that
goes up to 63 024 and 25 so that's the
Ada coordinator is in the recommended
but that's a great question and now's
the time to figure that out exactly
right
right no I agree with you all right are
we happy
all right I see a lot of happy faces
okay so we are two more here so so Mike
we can cross this one out okay all right
all right thank you very much thank you
representative here from the banking
Department
we have a hard stop at four o'clock so
tonight
yeah
I thought there's 48 people 50 people in
thank you
all right thank you very much so what I
what I see here is 50 people
100 other phones
yeah so please introduce yourself thank
you thank you um good afternoon for the
record my name is Amelia galderi and I'm
the bank commissioner for the State of
New Hampshire with me is Michael
josonowski he is our director of
operations
absolutely yep uh so my first name is
Amelia
[Music]
e-m-e-l-i-a my last name is gal diary G
is in girl a l d as in dog i e r i
and I'm gonna let Mike spell his own
name because he has a tough one to spell
Mike it's easy Mike is easier the last
name it's a multiple jazanowski
we have lots of vowels in our names so
it's a j-e-s
i o n
o w
I'm the bank commissioner
yep and he's the director of operations
nope
yep no problem I appreciate when people
spell my name right so I'm happy to
spell it
um so thank you for this opportunity to
present um information about the banking
Department's budget proposal
so I I provided a handout for everyone
to consider
um I always like to start these budget
proposals uh discussions with a
statement of our mission uh whoa it is
the end of the day and I apologize
um uh information about our mission
statement because everything in our
budget ties back to the mission
statement and it is important so the
banking department is committed to
protecting the Public's interests
through the professional supervision of
the financial services it regulates so
what that means is we are a consumer
protection focused regulatory agency
that oversees financial institutions in
the state of New Hampshire so banks
credit unions trust companies as well as
a variety of licensed Consumer Financial
Services providers such as Mortgage
Bankers and Brokers money transmitters
Etc
um so
for the purposes of the budget the
banking department is divided into two
divisions one is the bank and trust
division that over that division
oversees the activities of 17 State
chartered Banks eight credit unions and
42 non-depository trust companies and uh
private Family Trust companies the
second division is the consumer credit
division they oversee the uh several
thousand Consumer Credit licensees so
again the Mortgage Bankers the mortgage
brokers servicers uh small loan lenders
money transmitters when you hear Money
transmitters you think may be Western
Union but it also comprises a growing
fintech industry so that's where we do
have a little bit of a touch on
cryptocurrency that you might hear in
the news and that sort of emerging
emerging technology division
um so those are our two divisions for
the purposes of the budget
um the banking department has 48
positions right now we have one position
that's actively being recruited to fill
one vacant position that's in the
process of being reclassified and two
vacant funded positions
so let's see the banking department is a
self-funded agency we are 100 other
funds what that means in Practical terms
is at the start of the fiscal year we
receive an appropriation from the
legislature and the state treasurer via
the state treasurer
um and over the course of the year we
charge fees fines and at the end of the
year an assessment on all of our
regulated entities to basically recruit
recoup that appropriation so at the end
of the year we net nothing to the
general fund
uh so in in effect we're right we're
funded completely by the private
businesses that we regulate
um so moving right along
sorry do you have a question okay all
right
oh
I don't I was gonna say I don't have a
spreadsheet so I apologize
okay
yep
oh
okay okay okay
I'm gonna keep going
um so I would direct your attention to
the handout for kind of a high level
report of the amounts we've requested in
our budget I won't belabor them
um there I'm in your handout but this is
just a summary really
um 80 of the banking 80 to 85 actually
of the banking Department's budget is um
salaries and benefits so we are
primarily people
um we have I.T equipment that supports
those people but for the most part all
people we don't have any equipment or
anything like that
um so flipping to the back of the
handout
um the banking department has been
tasked by the legislature with
regulating a vibrant and ever growing
number of licensed entities again
largely those are the fintech companies
at the top you can see the steady
increase
um and then non-depository trust
companies there's been a process ongoing
over the last 10 to 15 probably longer
than that years I've been at the bank
Department 11 and it's been going on the
whole time I've been here
um process of modernizing our trust
company laws to attract that business to
the state of New Hampshire so as a
result the bottom chart shows the growth
in those industries that are those
companies that are regulated by the
banking department and kind of shows the
progression of examiners that we
anticipate needing to cope with that
increase
in past budget Cycles we've been able to
absorb this growth by leveraging by for
example One Way leveraging information
Technologies and by making good use of
our existing positions we've been very
fortunate we have been lucky in filling
our positions
um so we we've been making good use of
all the positions we have however the
industry growth as you can see from this
chart is now beginning to outpace our
staff basically we are tasked with going
out into the field and examining all the
entities that are regulated by us on a
for trust companies for example it's
every 18 months it's different time
periods for different entities but
generally speaking we're we're basically
right now the growth is outpacing the
number of examiners we have
um and that is becoming a problem for us
so
um for this reason in this budget we've
made a targeted and strategic request
for two new positions in fiscal year 24
and three new positions in fiscal year
25 and then outside of the budget we're
going to take three existing positions
and reclassify them reallocate them to
best suit our needs to cut to regulate
that growing industry
the net result of all these moving
positions will be that we're going to
add a deputy director to both the
consumer credit Division and the
division that regulates the trust
companies and then we're going to add a
couple of examiners as well as a legal
person an attorney because
um as these entities come in they submit
these very um
technology driven and complicated
applications for licensure and it's
important that we have legal staff that
can review them so um basically at the
end of the day the goal accomplished by
our budget proposal is to provide the
banking Department with adequate
experience and professional staff to
cope with the extraordinary growth we've
been experiencing in the fintech
emerging fintech companies as well as
the exponential increase in trust
companies in the state of New Hampshire
so in summary that's my our budget
presentation it's all about people and
Staffing on getting the adequate staff
that we need and I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have
all right representative evil
very basic Define fintech
that's not a very basic question
surprisingly it depends on who you ask
um generally speaking when we say
fintech we're thinking of companies that
use technology to deliver Financial
Services
so for example we regulate PayPal when
you go and like make a purchase on
somebody and select I want to pay with
PayPal we will go in and examine that
transaction make sure they're complying
with rules and laws that's generally how
we think about fintech different people
could Define it slightly differently
though
than most regulated by us they're a part
of PayPal
representative Sweeney thank you the
product of PayPal on that same line
would like coinbase
okay so crypto is a little bit more
nuanced
um
for example FTX who you've probably
heard about in the news
um they um they held a license with us
as a money transmitter however
um with cryptocurrency we only regulate
a very narrow portion of that market so
the legislature limited our jurisdiction
to only companies or transactions where
say the company took your cryptocurrency
and gave him fiat currency that's the
transactions we regulate if the company
takes your cryptocurrency and gives him
cryptocurrency we don't regulate that
transaction so it's really a very narrow
portion of that particular industry that
we regulate
um so is there really two trillion
dollars somewhere in New Hampshire
that's what this page says oh
I couldn't speak to that
a AUA of public Trust Company billions
of dollars so it's actually trillion yep
so those companies do not have to be
located in New Hampshire
so they're located actually all over the
world
um we do have a company that has
operations in the UK
um the biggest company that we have is
Raymond James I believe they are out of
Florida I could be wrong about that
don't quote me but we that they don't
have to be located in New Hampshire to
be a Trust Company
but they contribute fees to your
department to our department yes they
take part in the assessment we examine
them we charge them fees for that
examination to the extent there was any
issue we would they would be subject to
our finding Authority does that mean you
go to Florida I don't personally go
anywhere
um
so we actually
um during the pandemic we found that we
could do efficient exams remotely so
we've mostly been doing our exams
remotely with a very limited on-site
visit just to make sure that everything
is as they say it is however for the
most part all these companies are
operating remotely so it's just as
efficient for us to um
do our examinations remotely for the
most part with some limited
if you find problems
does it become a matter for the Attorney
General no we have our own enforcement
Division I it could potentially it sort
of it depends
um entities that are subject to our
jurisdiction are exempt from the
consumer protection act so they come
they come under our jurisdiction for
enforcing unfair and deceptive trades
and practices or any violation of our
statutes that we have jurisdiction over
um so for the most part it's under us
but there could potentially be some
crossover
um for example you know one of our
license types is retail sellers which
are auto dealers who arrange financing
but obviously auto dealers take part in
a wide range of activities outside of
arranging financing so there tends to be
some cross crossover there you know
we'll get a Consumer complaint for
example that says a lot of things and
only a piece of it's ours but some of
it's theirs
in a nutshell
so
how often do you find the problems all
the time hardly ever so our um we have
strict confidentiality laws our reports
of examination investigations and
consumer complaints are confidential
um by Statute however if we take an
enforcement action that is a public
action and those are listed on our
website
um and we just revamped our website so
it's actually quite easy to navigate you
can sort it by the most recent
enforcement actions and see what what
has been happening recently but is it
one a week is it enforcement actions
and So lately we had um
had a change in how we license for
example auto dealers we um switched them
so they have to be licensed through the
Nationwide multi-state licensing system
we gained a lot of efficiencies that way
however there were some like hiccups and
getting people onto the system so we had
to enter into some consent orders for
people who had technology issues getting
onto the system so we basically license
them by consent while they worked out
those issues so like if you went on our
and yes representative evil
thing
um
two thousands
um they sort of go in there's two parts
of them one is the modernization of the
Cross mode which really is a member of
our jurisdiction
what does that mean though have I not
had this on the whole time I apologize
oh oh okay
um sorry
um so one part is the modernization of
the trust code which governs how estate
planning happens that's really outside
of our jurisdiction but I think it has
made New Hampshire a more attractive
state for trust companies to come into
in part to um to make to basically
capitalize on those changes and then um
most recently in 2015 we had a large
recodification effort of our trust
company banking statutes and Credit
Union statutes that really um
streamlined our statutes made us um I
think very easy to navigate in terms of
our laws as compared to other states
with a similar Trust Company Authority
and I think those those two things
working together have really um made us
uh attractive place to get a charter for
yes representative Griffin thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking the question
um does your department have any
exposure
in other words if you examine a trust
company or something and later on there
is a problem with it is there any
exposure to your department
you mean like legal exposure or
um yeah like legal exposure from like a
consumer perspective or yes okay
um
hmm
it's a legal exposure I think that would
be a question for the doj
um we are a division of state government
and there is like and I'm not an expert
so this is probably outside I am a
lawyer but this is not my field of
expertise but there is like sovereign
immunity and different things that would
I think protect the state
um but
I don't know if that's right you're
getting at it it might not be the best
person to answer that I suspect the
answer is no because if you if you had
three or four lawsuits against you you'd
probably be aware of it I would be aware
of that yes if we did have three or four
lawsuits against me yes I would know
that and I was General Counsel at the
banking Department um before I became
deputy and then commissioner so yes I
would be aware of that
the questions anyone yes representative
I mean would you anticipate the number
of public trust companies to increase
yes so um if you look at this chart um
uh my director of trust supervision
Nancy Daigle Bernard she's very good at
predicting kind of where we're going
she's been at the department for 30
years 29 years 29 or 30 years she's
pretty good at this
um and what I know we've seen since I've
been general counsel since that
recodification effort is about three to
four one time I think we had five new
ones in a year
um so it has become pretty predictable
right now um we had we did have exactly
42 in fiscal year 22 and right now we
have exactly three in the hopper
um so I think we'll probably hit 45 by
um fiscal year the end of fiscal year
23.
so are are these existing companies that
are moving do you do you see are they
new companies that are being formed it's
a mix
um I'd say
out of four you know
two of them might be new two of them
might be moving
um two of them might be you know
sometimes they're existing companies but
they're moving into a new business model
where they want to make use of a trust
company charter it really
what fraction of banks are nationally
chartered versus State China oh that's
that's in New Hampshire I don't know the
exact number of nationally chartered
Banks because they're not under my
jurisdiction but I could look that up
for you on the FDIC website I think they
can sort them by state to tell you who
has offices in New Hampshire for
nationally chartered they just generally
measured by number of branches or is it
number assets or something you could
probably sort it both ways
um so yeah because I would I would I
guess I would think that
if if something's State chartered then
it can only be in New Hampshire or it
could have branches elsewhere it could
es so in some ways are we competing with
Federal
um Charters I mean is there something
yeah if we want more Banks to be New
Hampshire chartered like yeah I think to
be like the Delaware of banks or
um so I so to be fair the 2015
recodification effort did revamp our
banking laws as well and in my opinion
is the lawyer who mostly had to look at
those laws made them so much easier to
read so to the extent that um that
process has already been undertaken I
think we've made good progress in that
direction
okay thank you other questions nope all
right
don't see that we have any problems with
this area no so we're all set all right
thank you very much so we'll see you all
tomorrow at
is it 9 30 or 10 I'm not sure
is it are we in the big room
it's a work session here we're here well